hey everyone welcome to simply launch
youtube channel in this session we will
be learning the software development
projects for beginners in 2022 but
before we begin i would like to take a
quick confirmation from our viewers if
we are clearly audible and the screen is
clearly visible if yes currently type
yes in the chat section and if there are
any changes that you need to do from our
end please do let us know in the chat
section
all right i see a lot of positive
responses from our viewers thank you so
it's clear that we can get started so we
have daily updates on multiple
technologies and if you are one of those
tech geeks in a continuous hunt for
latest technological trends then
consider getting subscribed to us and
don't forget to hit that bell icon so
that you can never miss out an update
from simply learn now without further
ado let's get started with the agenda
for today's session
first we will get started with top java
projects for 2022 then we will also go
through some top and most frequently
asked interview questions based on java
and followed by that we will get into
the top python projects for 2022 for
beginners and finally we will wrap up
the session by going through some most
frequently asked software development
oriented interview questions for
beginners in 2022. so i hope i made
myself clear with the agenda now without
further ado let's get started with the
session on the software development
projects for beginners in 2022.
over to our training experts
the top 10 java project ideas
so the first project that we will deal
today is the online career management
system
so this particular project motor is to
deal with the career management system
the system will be used for day-to-day
activities like buy written booking
delivery and non-delivery and
self-pickup etc
it is not easy to build this particular
project all alone as the technicality of
the project is a little complex for a
single programmer i would suggest you
that you get a team with you and also
look out for some automation in the
process by developing the relevant
software
robotic process automation is the new
normal in today's life the web enabled
interface allows the user to log in from
anywhere in the world and track their
career and also view the customer rating
the system is designed to integrate with
financial accounting to eliminate
duplication of data entry and is also
scalable to grow along with your company
the system needs to be built with
user-friendly screens rich in
functionality and features and finally
the major part it should maintain a high
level of data integrity
so with that abstract discussed now
let's look into the features offered by
this particular online courier service
as discussed in the abstract this
particular project should be providing
the features of order and dispatch of
the product information regarding the
customer delivery executive and followed
by the delivery executive we should be
also having a payment window which
manages the accounts and bill reports
so having said that let's now move into
the software requirements
so the software used in this particular
project is the programming language that
is java database is the microsoft access
and some convenient rpa tools and
finally the ide the id for this can be
anyone which has a good support for java
the most preferable one would be the
eclipse and then comes the intellij
netbeans and many more now creating this
kind of a project will give you a
valuable experience based on building a
fully fledged e-commerce website or an
application
i mean this is how the world's leading
applications like amazon flip cards or
motto etc are basically planned and have
reached greater heights today this kind
of project on your resume could make a
huge difference and who knows tomorrow
you might even get into one of those
companies and start working on their
projects or build a company of your own
followed by the online career system we
have the online voting system
now thinking apart from getting a job or
starting a new company of your own this
is something that we all need today in
this pandemic situation especially in
the current scenario the internet has
brought all the east to our living room
it has replaced physical banking to
internet banking ordering food online
buying movie tickets
buying clothes and household items to
consult your doctor for minor issues
bill payments and many more
yet for quite a long time going to
polling booth and standing in a long
queue to cast a vote has been persistent
and it has been challenging for the
government to motivate common people to
participate in the election system and
cast their vote just because there is no
other way to do such thing as such an
online voting system but all the credit
can be achieved by software engineers
who can make it possible soon for
everyone to cast their vote to their
respective candidate
as their own choice with an unmatchable
ease
this can be done just by click on their
fingers
this is an advanced java project
developed to show online voting
functionality followed by the abstract
we will get into the technicality of
this particular project so the first
phase of this particular project has the
admin phase where the admin has the
right to manage the candidates manage
the voters and their profiles and
passwords and finally election results
followed by the admin we have the voter
or the user of this particular
application the voter or the user gets
to
register himself or herself into the
application followed by that he can use
the login and logout options and next we
have the profile and password
managements so followed by that we have
the option to choose the positions to
vote and finally to cast the vote now
this particular project is an advanced
level java project developed to show
online voting functionality it showcases
the use of java servlets html and css
again coming into the ide the ide for
this can be anyone who has good support
for java the most preferable one would
be eclipse and intellij
followed by the online voting system we
will now continue with the online
healthcare management
named as the corporate medicare
management this e-healthcare management
system is a web-based project developed
in java the main aim of this particular
project is to provide effective
management of data related to staff and
patients in hospitals or clinics
the features offered by this particular
project should be as follows it should
optimize bed occupation the project
should improve the use of operation
theaters avoiding the cancellation of
operations to know how much emergencies
affect the administration of the
hospital departments or services which
include cancellation of operations
to optimize the allocation of human and
material resources to warts and shifts
to detect the influence of certain
diseases in the hospital services and
finally to find clusters of patients
the software requirement for this
particular project are as follows
we need dhtml for the front end
and java as the programming language
and data mining tool which is weka
and oracle for the database
javascript for the scripting language
and finally tomcat as our server the
e-health care management system is a
web-based application that assists the
management of staff doctors and patients
in an easy comfortable and effective way
here the concept of data mining plays a
vital role to develop an effective
health care management system
the proposed application aims to create
a friendly working environment for any
healthcare centers to overcome the
drawbacks in the existing system of
healthcare management
this system is very reliable and
flexible from all aspects so new
features and modules can be easily
integrated into the system in the future
followed by the e-healthcare management
system we have a new normal online
banking
not interesting and arousing for a
normal person but for a hardcore
programmer it is as exciting as a
rollercoaster ride in an amusement park
because this is how the major national
and multinational banks implement their
banking facilities in a wide range so
that their customers could experience
the ease of banking at their fingertips
one such type of project on your resume
could bring major highlight to the
recruiter especially if the recruiter is
from a banking or financial based
company
online banking system project is a model
internet banking site this project
should enable the customers to perform
basic bank transactions by sitting at a
corner of their home or office through a
phone or laptop the customers can access
bank's website for viewing their account
details and perform the transactions on
account as per the requirement bank
employees can login and add customer and
account information to perform
transactions with internet banking with
internet banking the brick and mortar
structure of the traditional bank gets
converted into a click and portal mode
thereby giving the concept of virtual
banking a real shape thus today's
banking is no longer confined to
branches
e-banking facilities banking
transactions by customers around the
clock globally the features you can
offer through this particular project
are
home page for online banking site
creation of new accounts login and log
out
manage profiles and passwords view the
balance of the account deposit the
amount into the selected account veteran
amount from the selected account
transfer the amount from one account to
another close the account so the
software requirements for this
particular project are java programming
language and and javascript for
scripting language and oracle for
database and tomcat for server
so followed by the online banking
project we have the online examination
project
online exams are normal for us nowadays
but this is totally limited to high-end
exams like cet gre cat etc the
requirement for this particular project
is increasing day by day because of the
current scenarios many schools and
colleges have now turned towards the
online education system and are looking
forward to hosting online exams for
student safety
online examination is a simple project
developed to provide an online platform
for faculty and students to conduct
online examinations and their
evaluations
this particular project has two parts
first is the admin part
admin has the right to add students
create one-time login
adding questions receive answers and
finally to evaluate followed by the
first part we have the second part which
belongs to the students
so the students can login update their
profile and password select answers for
the mcqs write answers to questions and
finally closing the session and logout
this particular project can be made a
grand success by making use of simple
java servlets and java programming
languages and server like apache tomcat
followed by the online examinations we
have the smart city smart city java
project can be a web-based software
developed to store the details of a
particular city the main purpose of the
project is to help tourists and other
visitors to a city by providing
information about hotels transportation
facilities air ticket booking shopping
details city news etc the smart city
java project serves the visitors as a
guide of the city and hence the project
is called as city guide project in java
using this project the details of the
city can be accessed from anywhere at
any time the implementation of the city
project promotes tourism and business
effectively
hotels can be searched more easily from
anywhere with the help of this online
software students can look out for
academic institutes located in the city
you can view the complete map of the
city using this project followed by the
abstract we have the features of this
particular project the features offered
in this particular project are login
update profile and password search for
the options select an option like
booking a ticket or hotel or anything
like
transportation etc and finally selecting
that particular option booking that
option and payment window finally the
confirmation of the order
this particular project can be fulfilled
by using the following software tools as
mentioned below
they are the java programming language
tomcat server scripting languages like
javascript etc and database as oracle
for interactive data storage
this could be escalated to another level
by following
designed drones that can act like a cop
act as a tourist guide for the people
touring the city a drone that has
capability to take pictures videos of
suspected activities and store it for
future reference a drone can intimidate
a cop if any suspected activities are
detected
there can be many drones in the city
with different functionalities and
finally you are required to implement
the functionality of the drone
to the users to interact with the drone
users could be travelers or corps or
travel agents or cab agents
the code for all these projects are
provided in the description box below
followed by the smart city we have the
bug tracking system
the bug tracking system is a web-based
application developed by java
programming language for software
companies
the main aim of this project is to
manage the errors or bugs that occur
during the software development phase
and cycle after the implementation of
this project the employees can update
the issue details solve the issues and
update the system for any location with
internet access
below are the features of this project
and source code of this project is
linked in the description box below
coming into features the software is
applicable in managing the bugs that
occur during the development of software
and tracking the older issues it
facilitates searching the facility to
bug history and solution
the system is fully secured and
authentication method is adopted
to manage security it stores the old
debug reports so that they can easily be
solved when they reappear the
application helps the project manager in
evaluating the works of the employees
and finally the proposed software is
capable of auto update when the latest
version is available
so the software requirements for this
particular project are
programming language which is java
web-based applications such as jdbc jndi
servlets jsp and oracle database or
access database as the database
followed by that the server deployment
is red hat jboss es etc and the client
side scripting as the javascript and the
id for this particular project would be
eclipse with all the my eclipse plugins
and finally the user interface can be
designed using html and css
so with this we can move ahead into the
next project which is the facial
recognition
the face recognition with opencv is an
open source computer vision library that
has tons of modules like object
detection face detection and augmented
reality
the major features that this particular
project offers are managing the user
faces facilitate face identification
easy login and logout store face ids
identify suspects with just images
enhanced way to find cyber criminals so
followed by the features now we should
look into the software requirements to
build this particular project so the
programming language we need for this
particular project is java and followed
by the programming language we need the
apache and framework
mingw64 and finally the cmake framework
so followed by the facial recognition
project we have the next project which
is the vehicle recognition
so java anpr is a number plate
recognition software which implements
algorithmic and mathematical principles
from artificial intelligence machine
vision and neural networks
so the features offered by this
particular project are high level
language for numerical computation
interactive environment for iterative
exploration mathematical functions
built-in graphics functions for
integrating matlab and many more so this
particular project can be fulfilled by
using opencv and java programming
language along with some natural
language processing
algorithms so followed by vehicle
recognition project we have a last
project which is the speech recognition
system
so speech recognizer converts audio to
text
java x dot speech dot recognition
package defines the recognizer interface
to build speech recognition plus a set
of supporting classes and interfaces
so the features or stages in this
particular project are to create a
speech recognizer allocate resources
load and enable grammar attach result
listener commit changes and finally
provide the process results
so this particular library is readily
available in java and you can code this
project using the java programming
language and an id such as eclipse so in
this session we are going to focus on a
particular project
and the project we are going to focus is
is about an atm application
so
you might have interacted with different
atm stores in your cities where you go
in you insert your card you enter your
pin and then you can view the balance
you can withdraw some amount you can
also deposit some amount from the atm
so we will try to look at it from that
perspective and and we will see what
kind of different
java and oops concepts we can use to
build such atm application
this is not a super versatile
application but this is just to give you
the idea of how to use those oops
concepts to build a simple or a complex
java application so let's start from the
options menu class because that will
give us the understanding of what kind
of functionality i'm using
and here you will use that
i am using different concepts which i
have taught you so far in this
particular series
so for example we are using the iu
exception we are using
the hashmap class we are also using a
scanner class which is used to take
input from the command line
so this option menu class is extending
the account class and i will come to the
account class in a while but let's see
what this option menu class is doing
this particular class has uh it is using
a decimal format money format class
which is to denote what kind of
format of money you have
then we have a hash map which is storing
the couple of
records of account number to pin mapping
so we create a map and inside the get
login method
we add couple of entries to the map
here the first entry the first integer
is pointing to the customer number
and the second integer is pointing to
the pin of the account of this
particular customer number
so if we call the get login method this
method will insert the data
after that it will ask the customer to
enter the customer number which has to
be one of these two
if you provide any other value then
there should be a logic in the
application to reject the input
so whatever a customer number the
customer inputs we pass that inside this
particular method called set customer
number
again i will come back to that
and once we have provided a valid
customer number then this method is
going to ask you to enter a pin number
and remember i told you this is the
customer number to the pin number
mapping so whatever customer number you
select from here
you will be providing the corresponding
pin number and again if you provide an
invalid pin number you will get an error
so that will all happen inside this try
block and
if you enter any invalid characters in
the pin number or the atm
customer number then you will get an
exception which i am writing inside the
catch block
this is all what we have seen so far
after the successful enter of the
customer number and the pin number i
fetch those values from these two
methods again i will talk about what
these methods are doing and again i'm
doing some basic validation checks but
things get interesting in this method
so what we covered so far was the get
login method let me close this method
here
so we covered the get login method the
second method which is defined in this
particular class is the account type
so here that we will ask the once the
customer has provided the customer
number and the pin number we will ask
the customer to provide the account type
this application supports two different
account types which are checking account
or a savings account so whatever so the
customer has to choose one of them again
we will be taking the input from the
command line using the scanner class
and then i'm using a switch case if the
customer entered 1 then i will execute
some code for the checking account which
is defined here in the case 1
and if the customer entered 2 then the
case 2 will be executed
and if the if it enters 3 then i will
exit the application by just printing a
sys out
so here i am using the switch case
construct to provide different options
to the customer
there is also a default case specified
here which says invalid choice
so this is what is happening in the get
account type method
the next method is if the customer has
used the option one
then we call the getchecking method
so let's go to the get checking method
which is the next method which is
defined in this particular class
so if the customer has selected a
checking account then we provide the
following functionality to the customer
which is the customer can view the
balance customer can withdraw the funds
customer can deposit the funds to the
checking account or they can just exit
the application
and again i'm using a switch case here
based on the customer types 1 2 3 or 4
the corresponding case block will be
executed for example if the customer
wants to view the balance then this
block will get executed and i call the
get account type method
if the customer selects the to as the
withdraw fund then get checkings with
withdraw input method gets called
and then get account type gets called
similarly if the customer enters three
then we deposit the fund and for that
also i have defined a method i will go
to the definition of these methods as we
go along but right now we are just
building the framework
so the get checking deposit input method
will be called whenever the customer
selects the option three
and for option four we just exit the
application
so this is what is happening in the get
checking method
now if from the account selection if the
customer selected second option which
was savings account then we were calling
get saving method
so this is where the get saving method
is defined
and again it is following the exact same
format as we saw in the get checking
method
where we present the following options
like viewing balance withdrawing the
funds and depositing the funds in the
savings account
and i have some methods defined here for
example get saving withdraw input
get saving deposit input
so we define the switch case here based
on the customer's choices here
and that is what is happening in the get
saving method so let me close this
method as well and that's all what is
defined inside the option menu class
so we ask the customer to enter the
customer number the pin number from this
get login method
then based on
that we provide
the customer the options to choose the
account type whether they can choose the
savings account or the checking account
and based on that whatever account type
they use we call the get checking or get
saving method and inside this method we
provide the customer the other options
to either withdraw the money deposit the
money or view the balance
that is what is happening inside this
option menu class
now let's go to the account class and
all the methods which we saw here will
be provided a definition in the account
class
you also see this option menu is
extending the accounts class so an
inheritance concept is being used here
let's go to the account class now
so this is the account class where i
have defined some private member
variables like customer number so now
you will be familiar with the customer
number pin number which i just described
and also with the checking balance and
the savings balance
you can also divide this account class
into two child classes where you have a
savings account class and a checking
account class
but for simplicity i've kept it to one
class
i'm initializing a scanner input which
will be used at multiple places and then
i have the setters and getters for these
four
member variables so you see set customer
number get customer number
if you remember this set customer number
was called in the option menu class if i
go back to the get login
once we ask the customer to enter the
customer number
we call the set customer number
which gets called here
similarly
we call the set pin number
which gets called here
similarly once we have said that we then
we were fetching the values using the
get customer number and the get pin
number
and that has that is also defined here
in terms of the getters
get pin number and get customer number
similarly we also have the getters for
the checking balance and the saving
balance
member variables
we do not have the setters for them
because they are not technically setters
but we have to calculate the balance
it's not a simple setter where you can
just return the value
so now let's look at some of the
business functions of the account class
how do you deposit how do you view the
balance how do you withdraw the balance
etc
so you see these two methods
which are specifically when the customer
is trying to withdraw the money from
their account
and these methods are basically called
internally by other methods so we will
come to that let's just understand that
we have two methods for calculating the
withdrawable amount or executing the
withdraw transaction for the checking
account account and the savings account
similarly i have two more methods here
which are calculating the depositing for
the checking account and calculating the
depositing for the savings account
and then we get the the bigger methods
which are using these calculation
methods so i define four calculation
methods so far
calc checking withdraw calc saving
withdraw
calc checking deposit and calc saving
deposit basically withdrawing and
deposit for both of the classes
and then we have these business
functions called get checking withdraw
input
and get saving withdraw input
get checking deposit input and get
saving deposit input
so these getter methods are something
which were being called from the option
menu class if you remember
if you go back to the option menu class
and if you chose the checking account
you get these options and let's say you
chose option two which was withdraw
funds or option three which was deposit
funds
then the corresponding methods which
were being called were get checking
withdraw input
and get checking deposit input
and this is the exact same method get
checking withdraw input
and
get checking deposit input
so if you see what is happening inside
this particular method is a couple of
sysouts
then we
take the scanner input amount and we
convert that amount to the double
after that we check
if the amount which the customer wants
to withdraw is smaller than the checking
balance or not and i'm running this
condition to check that
if the amount is smaller than the
checking balance
then we call the calc checking withdraw
method
which was defined right here
remember i told you that these four calc
methods will be used and this is how
they are used so here i'm actually
subtracting the value so whatever amount
the customer wants to withdraw
subtract that from the main balance and
then return the new main balance
that's what you do right if you have
thousand rupees and if you want to
withdraw 500 you subtract 500 from
thousand and then you send back the
remaining balance
so that is what is happening when we
call this method and then we print the
new checking account balance
that is what is happening in the get
checking withdraw input method
similarly if you chose option 3 which
was
depositing funds to the checking account
then get checking deposit input gets
called
and it is defined right here
get checking deposit input and here
instead of subtraction
we are doing the addition
so here i'm again doing a condition
check that the current balance plus the
new amount which has been supplied by
the customer from the command line
the total sum of it should be greater
than zero
what if the customer entered an amount
minus 5000
i should not allow that
so that's
the reason i'm putting this condition in
place and if
the current balance plus the new amount
which is supposed to be deposited to the
account the sum of it is greater than
zero then call the calc checking deposit
method
and this is where the calc checking
deposit method is present and where i'm
just doing present balance plus the new
amount and returning the new balance
that's all which is being done here
and you will see exactly similar logic
running for the
savings account as well if you look at
the get saving withdraw input which is
used to withdraw money from the savings
account so i take the input from the
command line and i run a condition check
that the amount which the customer wants
to withdraw
should be less than the current saving
accounts balance
if yes
then call calc saving withdraw method
which is defined here where i subtract
the amount from the current balance and
i return the new balance
and similarly you will see the exact
same functionality in the get saving
deposit where we add the money instead
of subtracting the money
and this is all what is defined in the
account class
so we talked about the option menu class
we talked about the account class and
now we have the atm class which is the
entry point which basically initializes
the option menu class and calls the get
login method
remember get login was the first method
which asks you to provide the customer
number and then get login called the
method to choose the account type and
the account type methods then call the
method to choose the option to withdraw
deposit or exit
so now we have built a fair
understanding of what is happening in
this application so let's run this
application
so i just ran this application and let
me bring the console here
it's first asking for a customer number
so i will go to the option menu class
and i will
pick up one of the customer number which
i have hard coded here
so i will provide that customer number
and hit enter
then it asks me for the pin number
so remember you have to provide the
correct pin number corresponding to the
customer number
so i'm taking this pin number just
copying it and pasting it here
then
this whole code got executed
and then it called the get account type
and the getaccount type method provided
you with these options which you see
here on the screen so based on what you
select the case block will get executed
and let's say i want to go for a
checking account so i press 1
and i hit enter
once you select the checking account the
case one gets selected and it calls the
get checking method
and the get checking method again
provides you with another menu view
withdraw or deposit or exit
so let's say i want to deposit fonts so
i press 3
and hit enter
it says the current balance is 0
and enter the amount you want to deposit
let's say i want to deposit 500
and i hit enter
you get the message saying the new
checking account balance is 500 and you
have successfully deposited the money
and that is what i did for the checking
account
now let's try to withdraw something from
the ticking account so you again get
back the same option because inside the
get checking method
we call the once we have successfully
done the business operation we again
call the
account type method to display the menu
again to the user
so let's see again select the checking
account class and this time i want to
withdraw the funds
remember i've added 500 there
so let's say i want to withdraw so i
choose the option 2 as the choice
current balance is 500 and it's asking
me the amount you want to withdraw from
the checking account
so i enter let's say 100 and i hit enter
when i do that the new checking account
balance becomes 400 so the 100 got
subtracted from the 500 and the new
balance is shown to your screen
you can do exactly the same thing for
for the savings account as well
and let's also run a negative condition
so i again select the checking account
and i want to withdraw the funds i
choose the option to
current balance is 400 and i i would
like to withdraw a thousand
what happens
if you do that we get a message saying
balance cannot be negative and this is
coming from the calc checking method
which which is defined here so what is
happening that i wanted to withdraw the
funds from the checking account
and here get checking withdraw
input.called
here
this condition was checked so the
checking balance was
400 and the amount i wanted to withdraw
was thousand so 400 minus thousand is
not greater than equal to zero so it
jumped into the else block and it said
balance cannot be negative
so this is how you can also build some
error conditions in your code which are
mandatory and which should be built
otherwise your application will have lot
of bugs
we can also exit the application so if
you just type three
and hit enter
you will exit from the application and
will again call the login method where
it will again ask you to enter the
customer number
so this is how you can run this
application and this is this was a
simple use case for you to show how you
can use the different object-oriented
concepts like classes objects methods
setters getters switch case etc to build
the application with the correct
business logic
and this is all i want to cover in this
particular session
and in the next session we are going to
have a look at another interesting core
java project just to build our
understanding more better about the code
java concept choose from over 300 in
demand skills and get access to 1 000
plus hours of video content for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
let's get started with working through a
code java project using all the
different oops concept we have learned
so far
so in this example
we are going to have a look at a
calculator application and this
calculator application supports
primarily four different operations like
addition subtraction
multiplication
and division
so let's see how do we build that app
so in front of me right now is open the
main class
so i have a main app class here which
has a public static void main method
and the first thing we see is a read
input class which is calling a read
method
so if you go to the read input class
it has a simple static method here which
is the read method and it is using the
scanner class
if you remember i talked about the
scanner class which is used to take
inputs from the command line from the
user
so
we initialize the scanner class and we
start taking the inputs and whatever the
user inputs in terms of the expression
let's say the user entered four plus
five or whatever that whole expression
gets sent back into this
input line
as a string
and that comes back here in that input
expression
once we have captured the input
expression the next thing we do is
divide the input expression
in the numbers and the operators
basically an expression would be either
something like
4 plus 5
into 3
divided by 2 let's say
let's say the user entered this
expression so this has either numbers
or operators
so that's what we are doing here we are
using the split method of the string api
the string class basically
and this split method is going to split
the numbers and operators into two
different string arrays
and here i am providing the split
expression that split at every time you
encounter one of these symbols
so this when you execute this particular
statement it is going to return a
numbers array
which will be
created based on this expression so you
will get an array with four five three
and two
and similarly in the
operator array you are going to split
or pick out the elements every time you
receive a number so this operator array
is going to hold this plus sign
this multiply sign and this divide sign
hope you get the understanding that we
are just splitting the whole expression
into two different arrays
where first array is holding only the
numbers and no mathematical expressions
and second array is just holding the
mathematical operators and no numbers
and we'll see why we need to do that in
the upcoming lines
once i've created this string array i
just want to
store or convert these string arrays
into a queue
so i convert this
array into a list by calling the array
dot as list so this expression is going
to return a list
and then i am going to
convert this normal list
into a linked list
and then going to store this linked list
into the queue of numbers
and i'm going to do exactly the same
thing for the operator array as well
converting this into a generic list
converting that generic list into a
linked list
and then storing this linked list as a
queue so i have an operators queue and i
have a numbers queue both of them have
been stored into a queue now
and then i'm using the poll method
if you remember the poll method of the
queue is used when you want to fetch the
first front element the head element of
the queue so whichever element is
sitting at the head of the queue will be
taken out the moment you call the whole
method
so i fetch the first
number from the numbers q
so in this case 4 will be fetched
here
in this variable
and after that i run a loop
on the numbers q
and i'm going to run this
particular loop still this particular
queue
is not empty if you see there is a
negation here so i am going to pick up
numbers one by one from this numbers
queue
till the number q becomes empty
and inside the loop
i do this exact same poll operation for
the operations queue so this operations
queue is holding all these mathematical
operations like plus star and divide
so i'm going to pick the head of it so
in this case plus will be picked up and
will be stored in this variable called
opr
and then i'm going to run a switch case
on this opr
basically as i told you in this
particular calculator application we are
supporting four operations which are
addition
subtraction multiplication and division
so i define a case for each of the
mathematical
expression so you see there are four
different cases here
and for each case i'm initializing a
class if it's a plus sign then i'm
initializing the add class
if it's a minus sign then i'm
initializing the subtractors
for multiplication
i have a class called multiply and for
division i have a class called divide
let's have a look at what these classes
are containing
so if i go to the add class first of all
it is implementing an interface called
operate
and this operator interface has just a
single method called get results
which is accepting a variable argument
array if you remember i told you that
you can also use a
array this is called a where arc
expression this means that this numbers
will be an array of arbitrary length it
can be a one element array it can be a
two element array it can be a four
element array or whatever you supply but
it is still going to be a fixed length
array but the length is going to be
dependent upon how much argument you
supply to this particular method
so that is what this interface operate
is doing it just has one method declared
which is called get result which is
accepting an array of numbers so
if the add class is implementing the
operator interface then it has to
override the get result method and here
it is just doing a summation of all the
numbers which have been supplied so if
you supply four numbers it is just going
to add up those four numbers and return
the sum
and
the exact same kind of logic or similar
logic will be seen in other
operate classes so if i go to the
subtract class
it runs the exact same operation but it
subtracts the values
if i go to the multiply class it is also
implementing the operate interface and
in the get result it is just multiplying
all the values
similarly in the divide class
it is also implementing the operator
interface and it is dividing all the
numbers one by one
so it's doing pretty much the same thing
in terms of the
expression and the logic
the only difference is whether you are
using an add operation or a subtract or
multiply or a divide
so we have checked all these classes and
the operator interface as well
and let's go back to the main app now
now you also see that i've defined a
reference of operate here and each of
the switch case block
i'm assigning
the object type to this interface
reference so i'm using the concept of
dynamic binding which we talked about
when we talked about interfaces
that we can also do dynamic binding
where we can assign an object
to an interface type
and the object type will depend upon the
expression
so once we have filled that based on the
case
while
filtering out this expression and
picking up plus star and divide
sequentially
then we go to the next line outside the
switch case block which is to pick the
next
number from the queue
remember we already did one poll here
so as per this example 4 was here in
this res
and now when we do this number dot poll
again
five will be picked up because that will
be the next head of the queue
so we pick up five here
and then we call operate dot get result
now this get result will be called based
on the expression which was encountered
first
in the queue
again looking at the example the first
expression encountered will be plus
so the expression was plus so the
operate type object is of add type
and when you call operate dot get result
the get result method of add class is
going to get invoked
and it is going to sum 4 and 5. this res
is holding 4 right now
based on what i described here numbers
dot poll
and this num is holding the
the second operand basically
basically 5 here so 4 plus 5 gets
evaluated here in this case
and then it again goes back here and it
checks if the number q is now empty no
it is still not empty because we still
have 3 n2
left there
so
again it does the operations.poll and it
picks up multiply sign here
then it again runs the switch case since
it's a multiplier sign it will go here
and it will initialize the operate
interface reference as the object of
multiply class
then coming here it will do a numbers
dot poll
and this time the numbers dot poll is
going to pick up 3
so 3 will be picked up here
and then the current value of result
which is already 9
4 plus 5 was 9 the current value of
result will be updated here so rest will
be 9 here and num will be 3 here and
when you call operate dot get result the
multiply classes get result will get
called and it will say 9 into 3
which will become 27
it will again go back here to this
particular line and it will check again
if the numbers queue is now empty no it
is still not empty because we still have
one element left
then it pulls
uh the queue of the operations where the
expression divide is present there which
is the only element left in this
particular operations queue
and since we have the opr value as
divide
this case block gets called and the new
divide class gets initialized the divide
class basically gets initialized
and
we come here and we do numbers dot poll
now the last number which is available
in this queue is 2 which gets picked up
here
and then we again call operate dot get
result this time since the operate
object refer object uh operate reference
type was of divide class type
so when we call operate dot get result
the divide operation or the get result
method of the divide class
basically this method will get invoked
and it will divide the current value of
result which was
4 plus 5
9 into 3 which was 27 so it is going to
divide 27
by
2 which was the last value of the
numbers dot poll
it is going to execute 27 by 2 and
whatever value it gets it is going to
store a value back into the rest
variable and then it is again going to
go back here
and again going to check the condition
if the numbers q is
not empty but now the numbers q is empty
because 2 was the last element so it is
going to come out of the loop and it is
going to print the final result
that is how this whole program is
working
now let's try to see this in action and
will try to execute the exact same
expression
so if i right click and go to run as and
run this as java application
and i supply an expression saying 4 plus
5
star
3
divide 2
and if i now hit enter
i get the value as 13.5 which is exactly
what we ran through because 4 plus 5
will be evaluated first which will
result into
then 9 into 3 will be 27
and 27 divided by 2 will be 13.5 exactly
so this is how this whole program is
running where we first take the inputs
and then we divide the input into
numbers and operation arrays or in fact
queues
and once we have those queues built up
then we pick up the first number
and we keep running this loop till the
numbers q is not empty
inside the while loop at each step
we pick up the first expression or the
operator we check what is the operator
whether it is an addition subtraction
multiplication or division operator and
whatever kind of operator we have we
initialize the corresponding class of it
and then
we
fetch the next
value in the numbers q and then we call
the get result based on the expression
and whatever result we get from the get
result we store it back into the rest
variable so we keep updating the rest
variable at every step so that's the
reason the result of 4 plus 5 gets
stored in the rest and next time you are
calling the get result for a multiply
operation here the rest value is 9 now
and it says 9 into 3 again in the next
time the rest value will be updated to
27 because we are storing the result
back into the result variable
so this is all i want to cover in this
particular session where we looked at an
example of a calculator application
purely from the console standpoint
obviously there can be lot more stuff
which we can do into this particular
application make it more error-free and
cover a lot of corner cases like
validating the inputs etc
also
looking at or putting some conditions
around the exception handling handling
the divide by zero scenario etc which is
not here but this is just to show you
the basic idea of how you can build
simple to complex cli applications using
the core java concepts
so in this example we are going to have
a look at a calculator application
and this calculator application supports
primarily four different operations like
addition subtraction multiplication and
division so let's see how do we build
that app so in front of me right now is
open the main class so i have a main app
class here which has a public static
void main method and the first thing we
see is a read input class which is
calling a read method so if you go to
the read input class it has a simple
static method here which is the read
method and it is using the scanner class
if you remember i talked about the
scanner class which is used to take
inputs from the command line from the
user so we initialize the scanner class
and we start taking the inputs and
whatever the user inputs in terms of the
expression let's say the user entered
four plus five or whatever that whole
expression gets sent back into this
input line as a string and that comes
back here in that input expression once
we have captured the input expression
the next thing we do is divide the input
expression in the numbers and the
operators basically an expression would
be either something like
4 plus 5
into 3
divided by 2 let's say let's say the
user entered this expression so this has
either numbers or operators
so that's what we are doing here we are
using the split method of the string api
the string class basically and this
split method is going to split the
numbers and operators into two different
string arrays and here i'm providing the
split expression that split at every
time you encounter one of these symbols
so this when you execute this particular
statement it is going to return a
numbers array which will be
created based on this expression so you
will get an array with 4 5 3 and 2.
and similarly in the
operator array you are going to split or
pick out the elements every time you
receive a number so this operator array
is going to hold this plus sign this
multiply sign and this divide sign hope
you get the understanding that we are
just splitting the whole expression into
two different arrays where first array
is holding only the numbers and no
mathematical expressions and second
array is just holding the mathematical
operators and no numbers
and we'll see why we need to do that in
the upcoming lines
once i have created this string array i
just want to store or convert these
string arrays into a queue so i convert
this array into a list by calling the
array dot as list so this expression is
going to return a list
and then i'm going to convert this
normal list into a linked list and then
going to store this link list into the
queue of numbers
and i'm going to do exactly the same
thing for the operator array as well
converting this into a generic list
converting that generic list into a
linked list and then storing this linked
list as a queue so i have an operators
queue and i have a numbers queue both of
them have been stored into a queue now
and then i am using the pole method if
you remember the pole method of the
queue is used when you want to fetch the
first front element the head element of
the queue so whichever element is
sitting at the head of the queue will be
taken out the moment you call call the
whole method
so i fetch the first
number from the numbers q so in this
case four will be fetched here in this
variable and after that i run a loop on
the numbers q and i'm going to run this
uh particular loop till this particular
queue is not empty if you see there's a
negation here so i'm going to pick up
numbers one by one from this numbers q
till the number q becomes empty and
inside the loop i do this exact same
poll operation for the operations queue
so this operations queue is holding all
these mathematical operations like plus
star and divide so i'm going to pick the
head of it so in this case plus will be
picked up and will be stored in this
variable called opr and then i'm going
to run a switch case on this opr
basically as i told you in this
particular calculator application we are
supporting four operations which are
addition subtraction multiplication and
division so i define a case for each of
the mathematical expression
so you see there are four different
cases here and for each case i'm
initializing a class if it's a plus sign
then i'm initializing the add class if
it's a minus sign then i'm initializing
the subtractors for multiplication i
have a class called multiply and for
division i have a class called divide
let's have a look at what these classes
are containing so if i go to the add
class first of all it is implementing an
interface called operate
and this operator interface has just a
single method called get results which
is accepting a variable argument array
if you remember i told you that you can
also use a ver arg array this is called
a
expression this means that this numbers
will be an array of arbitrary length it
can be a one element array it can be a
two element array it can be a four
element array or whatever you supply but
it is still going to be a fixed length
array but the length is going to be
dependent upon how much argument you
supply to this particular method so that
is what this interface operate is doing
it just has one method declared which is
called get result which is accepting an
array of numbers
so
if the add class is implementing the
operate interface then it has to
override the get result method and here
it is just doing a summation of all the
numbers which have been supplied so if
you supply four numbers it is just going
to add up those four numbers and return
the sum and the exact same kind of logic
or similar logic will be seen in other
operate classes so if i go to the
subtract class it runs the exact same
operation but it subtracts the values if
i go to the multiply class it is also
implementing the operate interface and
in the get result it is just multiplying
all the values
similarly in the divide class it is also
implementing the operator interface and
it is dividing all the numbers one by
one so it's doing pretty much the same
thing in terms of the
expression and the logic the only
difference is whether you are using an
add operation or a subtract or multiply
or a divide
so we have checked all these classes and
the operator interface as well and let's
go back to the main app now now you also
see that i've defined a reference of
operate here and each of the switch case
block i'm assigning the object type to
this interface reference so i'm using
the concept of dynamic binding which we
talked about when we talked about
interfaces that we can also do dynamic
binding where we can assign an object
to an interface type and the object type
will depend upon the expression so once
we have filled that based on the case
while filtering out this expression and
picking up plus star and divide
sequentially then we go to the next line
of outside the switch case block which
is to pick the next number from the
queue remember we already did one poll
here
so as per this example 4 was here in
this rest
and now when we do this number dot poll
again
5 will be picked up because that will be
the next head of the queue so we pick up
5 here and then we call operate dot get
result now this get result will be
called based on the expression which was
encountered first in the queue again
looking at the example the first
expression encountered will be plus so
the expression was plus so the operator
type object is of add type
and when you call operate dot get result
the get result method of add class is
going to get invoked and it is going to
sum four and five this rest is holding
four right now based on what i described
here numbers.poll
and this num is holding the
the second operand basically basically 5
here so 4 plus 5 gets evaluated here in
this case and then it again goes back
here and it checks if the number q is
now empty no it is still not empty
because we still have three and two left
there so
again it does the operations dot poll
and it picks up multiply sign here
then it again runs the switch case since
it's a multiply sign it will go here and
it will initialize the operate interface
reference as the object of multiply
class then coming here it will do a
numbers dot poll and this time the
numbers dot poll is going to pick up 3
so 3 will be picked up here and then the
current value of result which is already
9 4 plus 5 was 9 the current value of
result will be updated here so rest will
be 9 here and num will be 3 here and
when you call operate dot get result the
multiply classes get result will get
called and it will say 9 into 3 which
will become 27 it will again go back
here to this particular line and it will
check again if the numbers queue is now
empty no it is still not empty because
we still have one element left
then it pulls uh the queue of the
operations where the expression divide
is present there which is the only
element left in this particular
operations queue and since we have the
opr value as divide this case block gets
called and the new divide class gets
initialized the divide class basically
gets initialized and we come here and we
do numbers dot poll now the last number
which is available in this queue is 2
which gets picked up here
and then we again call operate.getresult
this time since the operate object refer
object operate reference type was of
divide class type so when we call
operate.getresult the divide operation
or the getresult method of the divide
class basically this method will get
invoked and it will divide the current
value of result which was 4 plus 5 9
into 3 which was 27 so it is going to
divide 27 by 2 which was the last value
of the numbers dot poll so it is it is
going to execute 27 by 2 and whatever
value it gets it is going to store the
value back into the rest variable and
then it is again going to go back here
and again going to check the condition
if the numbers queue is not empty but
now the numbers q is empty because 2 was
the last element so it is going to come
out of the loop and it is going to print
the final result that is how this whole
program is working now let's try to see
this in action and we'll try to execute
the exact same expression
so if i right click and go to run as and
run this as java application
and i supply an expression saying 4 plus
5
star
3 divide 2
and if i now hit enter i get the value
as 13.5 which is exactly what we ran
through because 4 plus 5 will be
evaluated first which will result into 9
then 9 into 3 will be 27 and 27 divided
by 2 will be 13.5 exactly so this is how
this whole program is running where we
first take the inputs and then we divide
the input into numbers and operation
arrays or in fact queues and once we
have those queues built up then we pick
up the first number and we keep running
this loop till the numbers q is not
empty inside the while loop at each step
we pick up the first expression or the
operator we check what is the operator
whether it is an addition subtraction
multiplication or division operator and
whatever kind of operator we have we
initialize the corresponding class of it
and then we
fetch the next value in the numbers q
and then we call the get result based on
the expression and whatever result we
get from the get result we store it back
into the rest variable so we keep
updating the rest variable at every step
that's the reason the result of 4 plus 5
gets stored in the rest and next time
you are calling the get result for a
multiply operation here the rest value
is 9 now and it says 9 into 3 again in
the next time the rest value will be
updated to 27 because we are storing the
result back into the result variable
so this is all i want to cover in this
particular session where we looked at an
example of a calculator application
purely from the console standpoint
obviously there can be lot more stuff
which we can do into this particular
application make it more error free and
cover a lot of corner cases like
validating the inputs etc also
looking at or putting some conditions
around the exception handling handling
the divide by zero scenario etc which is
not here but this is just to show you
the basic idea of how you can build
simple to complex cli applications using
the core java concepts let's get started
with spring boot and how we can build a
simple application using spring boot
before we go further let's understand
why we need spring boot and the basic
idea of spring boot is to build restful
web services if you want to know more
about what are restful services please
you can read about the restful concept
as a concept what does rest stand for
but the basic idea is that if you are
accessing anything over http then that
particular component can be built as a
restful component and spring boot is the
most popular choice for building restful
web services today and even in fact
micro services which you might have
heard about so you can build
microservices which also run on https
using spring boot so what i'm showing
you right now is the official guide of
spring which you can use to build an
application with spring boot it will
list down all the requisites which you
need in terms of the
jdk installations maven on and how to
complete this guide etc etc you can
again use the same springs initializer
which i talked about in the previous
session you can use this to generate a
spring boot project for you specifically
so all those options are available here
so i've already done that and i'm not
going to repeat what i just did in the
previous session and will directly jump
to an ide where i have created a sample
spring boot application and the
structure here you can see the structure
would look very similar with one change
that in the previous example when we
were dealing with mbc we had an src main
resources folder and that src main
resources folder was having all the web
components or the htmls but since in
restful web services you do not render
the html but you just send back the
response the response can be the
response body can be pure xml or it can
be pure json but you do not send back
and view and that's the main difference
between spring mvc and spring boot that
in spring mvc it will you are required
to return a view technology like in the
in the previous session we sent a dye my
life template which is basically in html
you can also written a gsp but with
spring boot you do not deal with the
view technology and that's the world we
are living in today when you write
spring boot you do not have to worry
about how this is going to be rendered
on the web page whether it is going to
be rendered using html or what not what
you need to take care of using spring
boot is to return the right response
body the exact text of the response and
that's it so with that in mind the
spring boot was born and the structure
apart from that the structure would look
very similar there is a palm.xml here
which will provide all the list of jars
and dependencies which are required for
this particular project so you can see
all the dependencies here pretty much
the similar ones we have a starter web
we have a starters test and we have a
spring boot maven plugin and we have an
application file which is the entry
point again having a public static void
main method so you need to put the at
the red spring boot application at the
top of the class to make it an entry
point if you don't do this spring boot
will not run this class and spring boot
will
even not run your application so what we
are doing as part of this example that
we are just printing all the beans which
are provided by spring that's all we are
doing like i said it's a very
lightweight and introductory session so
we will keep the logics to minimum and
i'm just getting all the bean
definitions sorting the bean definitions
and just printing them one by one how do
you get the bean definition you get that
with this application context class
which is returned when you run the
application and how you run the
application is basically using this line
where you say spring application dot run
and you supply application dot class
with any command line arguments which
you might want to use once you do this
it is going to return an application
context object to you and the
application context object can be used
to get all the bean definitions by
calling this method which says get bean
definition names so that's the basic
logic which is being run in the main
class now we also have a controller but
this time it's not a web controller but
it's a rest controller so you see in the
previous example we just had written
something like this it was just a pure
controller but here we have become more
specific we are saying that hey this is
not a simple mvc controller but this is
a spring boot controller or technically
a rest controller so spring provides a
separate annotation for that which is at
the rate rest controller so you write
that particular annotation or that on
the top of the controller class which
you are creating and then you provide a
request mapping similar to what we did
in spring mvc but while you return it
you do not return a view technology you
just return the raw response here i am
just returning a string but you can
return a json object you can written an
xml object or whatever you want to but
not a view technology that's what i'm
doing like like you can see there's
literally nothing i'm doing in this it's
just a simple
string return statement which i have
printed here and that's all the code i
have right now here i just have these
two classes okay so that was all about
what i have written in the project and
now it's time to run the project so i
have just reached to the location on
inside my terminal where the project
bomb.xml was present and if i just do an
ls you will see that there is a pom.xml
available here and all the code directly
is also available here so now i will
just run this application and to run
this application i'm just going to type
mvn spring hyphen boot colon run and hit
enter once i do that the spring
application is going to spring boot
application is going to get started and
let's go back to uh the controller and
actually the main app main end point and
see what we were doing there i did a cis
out here which said let's inspect the
beans provided by spring boot and then i
was printing all the bean names and if i
go back to the output i will see the
same line being written here which was
around let's inspect the beans so you
can see that message which says let's
inspect the beans provided by spring
boot and then all the beans which are
available in the application context are
printed here so that's that's the basic
idea which i want to give you that you
can actually build a spring boot
application and you can write your rest
controllers return a string body from it
and once this is run then you can also
run your application for from the web
browser as well so let's try to hit that
particular url which i wrote here so the
url of hello count so for that let me
just open a new cognito window and
our application is already running so if
i just say http localhost 8080 slash i
get this message here which says
greetings from spring boot and this is
the message which we were sending from
the rest controller so this validates
our understanding that we can invoke a
test controller which is a spring boot
rest controller via the same method but
this time we are not getting an html but
we are just returning this particular
string now you can use the string in any
ways you want so it depends upon the
consumer so that's all i want to cover
uh as part of the spring boot now spring
boot is a huge huge topic and we can
spend hours and hours talking about
spring boot but since this is more of an
introductory session so i just wanted
the concept to get introduced and
remember the value proposition of why
you would need spring boot the basic
idea is to build restful web services or
build restful micro services that's the
basic idea behind using spring boot in
your applications and also remember the
difference between web mvc update spring
mvc application and spring boot
application spring mvc is for building
web application spring boot is for
building restful applications which
might not have a web interface
integrated with them at that moment
let's get started with our demo of a
project which is using spring boot to
build a restful web service so a restful
web service is nothing but any end point
which you can access or you can consume
the data from via an http layer or via a
simply a web layer because most of the
web traffic which we deal with is built
on http so to take an example if you go
to any website where you sometimes see
on the top right corner you see today's
weather so how is that today's weather
coming in it's coming in via a rest web
service the website which you are
accessing is basically hitting an http
endpoint uh which is uh where the where
the weather application is sitting and
it asks for the weather data and the
dressed web application just returns the
data and that's how the website is able
to show you the current weather so
restful web services are everywhere and
they are the most popular way to build
applications today where you just build
your restful web service and you expose
an http url and then the consumers need
to just access that http url to consume
the data from your application and you
see this makes it very easy because
there is no data type restrictions there
is no tight coupling here it's just an
http endpoint so that's the basic idea
and we will look at a project where we
will be using spring boot to build a
restful web service and then we will try
to run that web service to save some
data and also to return some data so
here on the on the package explorer you
see i have created a project called rest
service and let's just walk through the
structure of it and then we'll go into
the details of it so we have an src main
java where i have a package and i have
bunch of classes here and before we go
to the classes let's first also access
the dependency file because every
project needs some dependencies some
jars to execute it for example spring
itself is basically a jar so you need to
include the spring jar in your project
so that your project can become a spring
project and there are generally two
dependency tools one is maven and one is
gradle in this particular project i am
using maven
dependency tool for downloading and
managing the dependencies which are
needed to run this project successfully
and the way you will find if it's a
maven project or if it's a gradle
project for a maven project you will see
a file called
pom.xml pom.xml and if it's a gradle
project you will see a dot gradle file
that's how you can spot whether the
project is using maven for dependency
management or it is using gradle for
dependency management so let's open the
palm.xml since it's an xml file it will
be a bit verbose but
if you just read it piece by piece it
will become easier to understand first
of all since this is a spring project i
need to include the parent dependency
which brings lot of good defaults
sensible defaults from spring boot
automatically and this is the jar name
this is the artifact id which is spring
boot starter parent so any spring boot
project you are starting do include this
parent this parent is basically bringing
all the dependencies from some other jar
and you can make your project as a as a
child of this particular parent so all
these spring
boot projects have this as a parent as a
standard practice after that you provide
your own details in terms of what is the
package name uh how do you want to see
the jar name on what is the actual name
what is the jar version etc etc you also
set the minimum required java version to
run this application and then you in the
dependency sections you provide all the
jars which you need to run your project
successfully both compile and run your
project successfully so we added the
spring boot starter web on dependency
which basically brings all the
dependencies around making a controller
or making a repository
context component scan all the
interesting features which spring
provides get wrapped up inside the
spring boot starter jar and you can
actually go to the mvn repository and
and have a look at what all classes it
provides it's a lot of classes so i'm
just telling you in a brief that it
provides all the restful functionality
then you have the next dependency as
spring boot starter data jpa which is
going to enable this project to also
have a database and if it has a database
then you need java to talk to the
database and the way spring suggests to
talk to the database is why are using
the spring boot data jpi library we will
see this how this library can be used
but basically this provides ways to
represent your java object in the
database and then you need to also add
the actual dependency of the database
and in this case we are using an
in-memory h2 database so i'm not using
an external database like mysql or
oracle or pos sql because that will just
make more configurations more
complicated i just wanted to keep it
simple and generally you in this h2
database you can easily access by adding
this dependency and it will be an
in-memory database created for you then
i've also added a spring boot starter
test here which will be used whenever
you are writing unit tests and you must
write unit test for your project and
then we need to add the plugin so that
springboot can run this project that's
all i have in the palm.xml now let's
move to the interesting part the java
section part let's start from the main
class
so this is how the main class looks like
where you have you just create uh any
any name with the class and then you add
a public static void main method inside
the public static void main method you
call spring application dot run and this
run method is basically going to run
your application and you just provide
the same class name which you just wrote
here so just say dot class and if you're
supplying any command line arguments it
can interpret that command line
arguments as well if you want so you'd
always need an entry point in an
application and this is the entry point
which spring boot supports and this is
if you see this code this is just normal
code to make spring be aware about this
class being treated as an entry point
you need to add add the red spring boot
application annotation on top of the
class this is one of the annotation
which is coming directly from the spring
boot library you can see this import so
once you add this then only spring will
be able to treat this class as an entry
point otherwise spring doesn't know
where to start from so when you run
spring it will fi it will try to find a
class with an annotation spring boot
application and then inside the class it
will try to find a public start a static
void main method and once it has found
both of them then it will just run the
application so very simple nothing fancy
here and what we are dealing with here
is a student object so we will try to
insert the student object and we will
try to retrieve the student object so
if you ignore these annotations which
have added it's just a pure pojo it's
just a plain old java object you create
a student class let's ignore this field
as well for now i'll just come back to
this annotation in this field but this
is just a student class it has three
fields as name age and address an empty
constructor and a parameterized
constructor and some getters
intentionally i have removed the setters
because generally whenever you are
building any enterprise grid application
you would like to keep your objects
immutable means once they have been
created you would not like somebody to
allow to change the values of the object
this just makes programming but much
more easy if you treat all the objects
in your application as immutable that's
why i have not added setters here it's
just considered a good practice so apart
from the standard things which we have
already seen there are two things here
which i want to talk about let's first
talk about this one so accurate entity
is the annotation which is coming from
java x persistent entity persistence
entity and this makes
springboot save this particular object
into the database this is the annotation
which you need to put on your class so
that springboot knows that this class
represents a table in the database so
you need to add this to make sure that
this represents a table second thing a
table will have a id it will have sort
of a primary key so i've created a new
column called id which is basically
representing the student's role number
or something or maybe a registration
number and here i'm using couple of more
annotations if you see these annotations
are also coming from java x persistence
library and these annotations will
basically allow the a new id to be
created every time you create a student
object so you don't have to specify the
value of this id variable springboot
will automatically generate a new id
value every time you create a new
student object and how does it generate
you you can provide the generation type
as well so currently i've just said that
set it as automatic but you can set it
as identity sequence or rate or control
by table you can also see the
explanation of each of these here but
i've just kept it as auto which
basically
let the persistence provider pick any
appropriate strategy for the particular
database in our case the database is h2
so that's about the entity class let's
call this as entity class now let's move
to the repository so you need a
repository class
like i explained in dots in that three
tier architecture you always need a dow
layer or a repository layer to store
your student object into the database so
we have enabled the student object to be
saved but we need a handler which can
save this particular file this
particular object into the database and
the repository classes are the classes
which will allow you to do that so you
create a very simple interface you what
you name whatever you want to name your
interface as and then you say extends
jpa repository the type of the object
and the unique identifier of the object
so the type of the object is student
here and the unique identifier of the
student object is the id which is of
type long so you need to just supply the
types type of the object type of the
primary key or the type of the unique
identifier and this annotation is coming
from spring boot you can see
specifically spring boot data library
which we added so you just need to
create an interface extend it from jp
repository and make sure that you add
this annotation as well spring heavily
uses the concept of annotations and this
will help spring understand that this is
a repository layer class and it will
apply some more metadata to this class
while this class is running in the jvm
so what happens here you just created an
interface you did not provide any method
to create or any method to delete or any
method to get a student object because
all of that is automatically provided by
springboot via the jpi repository class
if we go inside this class and if you
scroll down you'll see the find all
method find all find all by id save all
flush save and flush delete etc and if
you go further up this also extends the
paging and sorting repository which
provides pagination and sorting
facilities but the interesting one is
that pagings and sorting repository
again extends a club repository and if
you go to the crud repository you will
find all the basic methods to save an
entity save multiple entities find an
entity by the id that's why it needed
that long type to make sure this that it
can execute this method you can check
the existence of an object find all the
entries find all by id count them delete
them so all the basic crud functionality
so we call them as crud because the
reason it is called crud because create
read update delete that's the basically
the
generic acronym so because uh this cred
repository provides all the methods and
their implementations automatically we
do not need to write any code at all so
that's why spring boot is so awesome and
that's why springboard is very popular
because it's zero code in the repository
and you still get all the crud
functionality so that's about repository
now we have covered the entity class we
have covered the repository class we
have covered the entry point class now
the only thing which is remaining is the
is the
end point the http endpoint which i
talked about and that you can create by
creating any class generally try to
suffix it with the controller so that
your core developers can easily find
this class and make sure that you put
add the red rest controller annotation
on top of it this annotation will allow
string to treat this particular class as
an end point class then you can auto
wire the student repository so if you
remember i talked about the whole
dependency injection and inversion of
control so here dependency injection is
in action so here you are just telling
student controller to auto wire the
student repository and now what will
happen that at run time student
controller or actually spring will
automatically create an object of the
student repository and supply that
object of student repository to student
controller so you as developer do not
have to create an object of student
repository explicitly that's the benefit
and that's how the dependency injection
is working because you inverted the
dependencies now the dependency is just
injected into the class and as a
developer you don't have to take control
of creating the objects it's the spring
which will automatically read the
autobot annotation and will
automatically supply an object whenever
it is required then i have two methods
here since we are talking about http
endpoints so i have represented a post
method here and a get method here the
way you will write a post method is via
the rate post mapping annotation and
then you can provide the url path on
which somebody should call your endpoint
to save something so for example
somebody can call it http localhost 8080
student slash create whenever they hit
that url the control or that request
will directly hit this particular method
why because you have provided the url
mapping here in the post mapping
annotation so since it's a post method
there would be request body what is the
actual request body which the client is
sending and you can represent its
request body with the add direct request
body annotation and you can provide the
type of the request body and here i'm
saying that hey if you want to access
this particular url yes all good but you
need to supply me with a
text representation of the student
object or a json representation of the
student object and then i inside the
method i'm calling student repository
dot save which is going to save the
student object which is coming in so you
see there's a lot going on here i will i
will show you how the student is
represented in the request body as well
and then i will come back to how it got
converted from json to java but this is
how you can store this particular
student object you can hit this api as
many times as you want and keep
inserting a new student object every
time then if you want to fetch a
particular student then you can do that
by supplying the slash student and then
in the curly braces there's an id
written here so basically you can supply
the value of the id of the student so
generally there would be another method
here which would be find all to see all
the students
and with their id and then you can pick
a particular student's id supply that
student id value here dynamically that's
why at the curly braces curly braces
supports dynamic value so here it can
insert 1 2 3 or whatever the student id
you want to fetch the value for you
provide that value in the student slash
id and all good then some if somebody is
hitting the url with saying localhost
8080 slash student slash 1 then student
with the id 1 will be returned from the
request and you need to put add direct
get mapping to make sure that this
method is treated as an http get method
and you can provide the type you can say
get student and here this dynamic value
is captured with the add the rate path
variable because you need to know the id
right whatever id somebody has supplied
it in the url you need to capture that
ide and then use that ide for calling
the repository so that's you can do that
by using the add variate path variable
so here i'm just saying whatever id is
coming in i will store that value inside
this ide once i've done that then i can
again call student repository dot find
by id which is again a built-in method
provided to me by the crud repository i
can supply the id and this actually is
going to return an optional object which
is uh which is an object which may or
may not contain a value so it's a just a
types of defensive programming style so
this will return an optional and you can
call a get method to return the actual
student object this will return an
optional of student so option of student
means that this optional object may have
a student or may not have a student why
did string do that because the id
somebody is supplying that id can be
invalid also right so optional object
tree takes care of that that if there is
no student found then you will not get a
null pointer exception and if there's a
student found you can return that so
it's just a defensive programming style
which spring has adopted by returning an
optional of the student object rather
than directly the student object but if
you are confident that this particular
option of student object does contain a
student object then just call
optional.get which i have called here
which will return the actual student
object sitting inside the optional
object you can read more about the
optional object and its usage uh from
the official java docs and there are
tons of examples available on it on
internet so this is about the controller
we have covered all the classes now it's
time to run the application so you go to
the command prompt you go to the
particular
file folder location and there
you just say mvn spring hyphen boot
colon run so i just hit enter and this
is going to
run the application it's going to split
some logs here and if everything is fine
you will not get an error and you will
just be getting a message saying that
application got started and it's running
on tomcat localhost 8080 with no context
url so this is not a web application
this is a rest full web service right
this is a restful service this is not a
web application so there is no web
interface so how do you access this you
just have an http url so you can use any
of the rest client available on the
internet there are probably hundreds of
different clients available on the
internet you can choose any one of them
i am using advanced rest client which
you can also install as an extension
from the chrome browser itself so if you
just if i just open the chrome browser
and i just say rest client if you just
write this and hit enter you will get
many different options and the first
option you get is from google play
stores app store so you can go to the
app store that basically the chrome web
store not the play store but the chrome
web store and you can just install this
since this is already installed you can
click on launch app and it will open
this interface for you so this is pretty
uh this is not a tutorial for advanced
rest client so i'll just be quick here
you can choose the method type which you
want to hit so let's say you want to do
a post and then you can provide the url
here so remember the url which we put
here in the controller method this has
to exactly match so http localhost slash
student slash create should be the url
so let me just copy paste this one here
okay so the url is good here it's a post
type of method which i want to do and i
want to hit this particular url now i
need to supply the content type and the
body so in the content type you can
choose application json because i'm
going to supply a json object and in the
body this is how the json object looks
like advanced risk client also provides
a nice visual interface to basically uh
create this json if you are thinking
that json creation is very tough it's
not actually tough it's just curly
braces and then you put key and value
key value comma let me just put an enter
here so that it's more readable so you
just put curly braces starting an end
and then you just put key value you put
a key which is the variable name and the
variables value variable name variable
value and these keys have to exactly
match the students properties so the
student.java had this name age and
address right so it has to exactly match
otherwise this will request will fail so
this is all good now i can send this
particular request when you click send
it is going to hit my spring boot
application which is running on
localhost 8080 it is going to call the
student slash create method it is also
going to convert this json into a java
object because here i am supplying a
java object so it will convert the json
which i'm sending from here to java
object automatically and it is going to
automatically save it here because i've
called the repository.save method so
let's hit send here once i hit send i
get a 200 okay it means everything went
fine and in the response header i get
the object back because i have returned
the object here you see this save method
is going to return the same student
object which you created
so everything is good here my object has
been stored here and now it's time to
fetch the object so it has already been
saved into the h2 in memory database and
you can obviously go and connect to the
in memory h2 database and have a look at
it but for simplicity i'm just going to
do this here and let's say the first
object is generally
added as the id 1 by default by the h2
database so let's hit this particular
url when i hit this url it is going to
hit the student controller here and in
the student controller it is going to
hit the get student method which is
having a student id url and it is going
to find the database with that id and if
it finds a student object with that id
it is going to return that so let's
confirm that now let's hit this
particular send button and it's going to
hit a get request with this particular
url springboard is going to find if a
student with the id 1 exists in its
database
so once i hit send i get a 200 okay and
you see in the response headers i get
the same student object back which i
added let's try with 2 now let's see
what happens i see 2 and i get 500
internal server error because there is
no object stored in the h2 database of
the spring application with the id 2 yet
because we only inserted one object
that's why only one student object is
there and the first id which h2 database
created for it automatically was one so
when you hit for get request with a
student id one you get the object when
you put any invalid value and you hit
this you get a 500 internal server error
you can also make it look nice by not
sending the 500 internal server error
and sending a nice exception from the
back end so from here you can also send
a nice exception that if this object is
not found you can say something like
that or else throw which is again an
optional object and here you can supply
a particular type of exception which you
want to supply instead of just throwing
500 internal server error but that's
just additional thing additional
defensive programming you can do you can
add more and more validations and
constraints into this project as you
build this project in a more complex
paradigm so this is basically what i
wanted to show you that and that we have
created a spring up boot application we
have connected it to a database we
haven't created also an http endpoint
with student controller we ran that
application we used any random rest
client in my case i used advanced stress
client and we first did a post request
we provided the exact url the url has to
exactly match with the controller url
and then the body the request body also
has to exactly match with the student
objects property especially the case of
the names have to exactly match so if
this all this matches then you will get
a response back that the object has been
created if you want to fetch the value
of the object you're going to use the
http get method and you again provide a
url which has to exactly match to some
method in some controller in the spring
boot application which is running on
localhost and if you provide the right
id you are going to return get a valid
result if you provide an invalid id
you're going to get a 500 internal
server error and from here on you can
make this controller as robust and as
mature as you want you can add find all
method you can add update student method
you can add a delete student method you
can have all different kinds of filters
like for example return to me all the
students starting with the name a or
return all the first
students with the role number one and
hundred or between 100 so you can write
as many endpoints as you want and build
this application in
as with as much maturity and as much
complexity as you want
we all know that java is one of the most
sought programming languages in the
current id industry there are multiple
multi-million dollar companies which are
using java till today
so this video is completely dedicated to
help out the java developers and the
beginners in java programming language
to crack the most frequently asked java
interview questions
so without further ado let's begin with
our interview questions
at first we will start with the beginner
level interview questions
so in the beginner level interview
questions the first question we have is
what is jit
so the answer for this question is
jit is an abbreviation for java in time
compiler it increases efficiency of the
interpreter by compiling the byte code
in the run time
jitr just in time compiler compiles code
to machine level directly for higher
speeds of code execution
so basically just-in-time compilation is
a feature added to the interpreter of
java so this involves conversion of the
code directly to machine level during
the compilation stage this improvises
the speed of execution of a java program
now after the first question the second
question in the docket is
what is a class loader
now let's discuss the answer for this
particular question
so basically class loader is the first
file to load when you execute any java
program so the java class loader is the
integrated part of java virtual machine
so the functionality of class loader is
to load the class to the java virtual
machine while it is demanded to execute
a class
java has both strap extension and
application type of class loaders
so the third question in the docket is
what are the memory allocations
available in java
so the answer for this particular
question is
java provides multiple types of memory
allocations but the five major types of
memory allocations which are most
frequently used are class memory heap
memory stack memory program counter
memory native method stack memory
so the next question in the list is
will the program run if i write static
public void main so basically we write
public static word main but in case
imagine if i write the program as static
public void main will the program
execute properly so the answer for this
question is
yes
because java does not follow any
specific rule for the order of
specifiers you place in your program so
when you execute the program with such
pattern in your specifiers then the
program will compile successfully also
it will run successfully
so the next question we have is
what is the default value stored in
local variables
so in c programming language when you
declare a local variable or a global
variable or any type of variable
then the first value which is stored
inside that variable will be a garbage
value unless you initialize the variable
with a personalized value for example if
you declare a variable i equal to 0 then
you are storing a value in that variable
i that is 0. if we just declare it as
int i then the value stored inside that
i variable will be a garbage value so
similarly when you declare some kind of
local variable in java then what will be
the default value stored inside it
so the answer for this question is
neither the local variables or the
global variables or any primitives or
any object references do not have any
kind of default value stored in them
so followed by the fifth question we
have the sixth question
so what would be the output of the
following code segment is the sixth
question so this might happen
sometimes so basically what happens is
your interviewer will throw a question
at you which has a code segment so all
you need to do is decode that code in
your mind and provide the output so this
would be the code that we will be
dealing with
so you can see
our question has two printf statements
the first one has hundred plus hundred
plus a string which is simply learn and
in the second printf statement we have a
string that is e-learning company plus
100 plus hundred so what will be the
output of these two printf statements
so the answer for this question is
really simple
so we'll be having 200 simply learn as
the first output and e-learning company
1 0 0 1 0 0 as the second output why
let's check out the code segment once
again
so when you see the code segment once
again so the first printer statement has
100 plus 100 plus simply learn so jvm
here understands 100 as an integer value
and the plus symbol as an addition
operator here so followed by the
addition operator we have another
integer value so what jvm does is it
adds the two numbers hundred plus
hundred so followed by that we have
another plus symbol here so followed by
the plus symbol we have a string value
so here the jvm considers the plus
symbol as
a concatenating operator but not as an
addition operator so that's why the
first two numbers got added and the
result was 200 and the next two values
were concatenated so it became as 200
simply learned similarly in the second
printf statement the jvm encountered
with a string value
so it considered the plus symbol as a
concatenating operator similarly it
happened with the second plus symbol as
well so that's the reason we had
elearning
100100 as the second output
now followed by the sixth question we
have the seventh question
what is an
association so the answer for this
question is an association can be
defined as a relationship that has no
ownership over the other so to
understand this definition we can
consider a simple example
consider a person associated with
multiple banks so consider person x who
has got accounts in bank a bank b and
bank c
and similarly a bank is associated with
person x
that is a bank a bank b and bank c are
associated with the person x but no one
has ownership over the other a person x
who is an account holder with all the
three banks that is a b and c does not
possess any kind of ownership over the
three banks similarly
banks a b and c who has the customer
which is the person x but the banks do
not possess any kind of ownership over
the customer
so the relationship between the person x
and the banks abc can be considered as
an association
now followed by the seventh question we
have the next question that is the
eighth question
define copy constructor and java so the
answer for this question is as follows
a copy constructor in java is a
constructor that initializes an object
through another object of the same class
a copy constructor in java is really
helpful because when you want to copy a
complex object that has several fields
or when we want to make a deep copy of
an existing object then the copy
constructor is the one which will help
you out in this situation
so followed by the eighth question we
have the ninth question
what is a marker interface
so the answer for this question is
an empty interface in java is referred
as a marker interface
serializable and cloneable are some of
the popular examples of marker interface
so basically a marker interface is just
another interface but normally in
interface we provide some signatures so
these signatures belong to particular
methods so
in normal interface we just have method
signatures but not the complete
implementation or at least we'll be
having some variables but in a marker
interface we do not have any kind of
data manipulating method signatures any
data members nothing they have special
functionality unlike a normal interface
so followed by the ninth question we
have the tenth question
what is object cloning
i guess the word object learning is
completely self-explanatory yet the
answer for this question is it is an
ability to recreate an object completely
similar to the existing object this
process is known as object cloning in
java
java provides a built-in function or
method that is the clone method to clone
an existing object offering the same
functionality that of the original
object
so followed by the 10th question we have
our 11th question
why is java not completely object
oriented so this question might be a
little confusing but it's true java is
not completely object oriented but
what's the reason
yes i'll explain you why java is not
completely object oriented
so the answer for this question is java
is not considered as 100 object-oriented
programming language because of the data
types it uses
it still makes use of eight or more
primitive data types which are end flow
double and few others so this is the
only reason why java is not considered
as completely 100 percent
object-oriented programming language so
the next question is
define wrapper classes in java so the
answer for this question is
in java when you declare primitive data
types that is the end flow double etc
then the wrapper classes are responsible
for converting them into objects or
reference types just as we discussed
before
java is not 100 object oriented
programming language just because of the
primitive data types it uses so when you
include such primitive data types then
wrapper classes are the ones which
convert them into objects or reference
types for the ease of compilation and
execution of programs without any issues
so followed by this question we have the
next question
define singleton classes in java so the
answer for this question is in java when
you make the constructor of a class as
private then the particular class can
generate only one single object this is
the reason why such type of classes are
called as singleton classes
so followed by that we have our next
question that says define package in
java so if you use some of the popular
ides that is the integrated development
enterprises such as intellij or eclipse
then you might be familiar with projects
packages source files and then the class
file so basically you create a project
first and inside the project you will be
having your source folder and then you
will be creating your own package using
the source folder and inside the package
you will create a class file and inside
the class file is where you write your
java program so here the question is
define package in java
so the answer for this question is as
follows
package is a collective bundle of
classes and interfaces along with
necessary libraries and java files the
use of packages helps in code
reusability so basically when you create
a specific package inside that package
you will store all the class files that
you will be using in your java program
so not only class files in case if you
use any kind of connectors or any kind
of jar files or any kind of dependencies
for your java program you will include
all those inside the package so that the
requirements and the class files are
bundled together and
this helps out in code reusability
making sure that the
program files or the java files or any
dependencies are not juggling between
one package to the other or one file to
the other so using a package is
basically a good practice
so followed by this we have our next
question
can you implement pointers in java
program
so if you remember c programming
language we had pointers there
so we use pointers to directly access
the memory
so similarly can you use pointers in a
java program this is a little tricky
question for beginners but basically
it's really simple
now the answer for this question is
no
because java virtual machine
personally takes care of memory
management implicitly so java's major
motto was to keep programming simple so
accessing memory directly through
pointers is not a recommended action so
the answer is a big no you cannot
implement pointers in java program
so followed by that we have our next
question
differentiate between instance and local
variables
so the answer for this question is
really simple instance variables are
declared inside a class and the scope is
limited to only a specific object inside
which an instance variable is created so
followed by the instance variable we
have the local variable so the local
variable can be anywhere inside a method
or a specific block of code also the
scope is limited to the block of code
where the variable that is the local
variable is declared
now followed by the 16th question we
have our next question
explain java string pool so the answer
for this question is a collection of
strings in java's heap memory is
referred as java's string pool
so for example you wanted to create a
new string
consider your name so your name might be
some xyz so if you wanted to create xyz
string then you provide that particular
code to your jvm so what does jvm do it
will not directly create that particular
string first it will search for the xyz
string in your string port if that is
already existing in your string pool
then it will provide a reference to that
particular string in case if xyz is not
there
then the jvm will create a new string
that is the xyz string
so followed by this we have our next
question that is
what is an exception
so the answer for this question is an
exception in java is considered as an
unexpected event that can disrupt the
normal flow of the program
so for example just consider that you
are going to write a program for
division operator
so after you finish your program your
evaluator might want to test your code
to the extreme levels so instead of
providing a proper number imagine that
your evaluator is providing a wrong
input such as special symbols sometimes
0 or any other sort of input so if this
kind of input is provided to your
program then your program might crash so
you can avoid this kind of crash by
using exception handling so basically
you can use try and catch blocks so you
can embed your code inside the try block
and say to your program that if any kind
of wrong input such as special symbol or
zero is provided by the evaluator then
send a message saying wrong input or
divide by zero exception so this kind of
approach will provide an output but this
kind of approach will avoid your program
from crashing so this is how exceptions
are handled in real time so followed by
this we have our next question
what is final keyword in java
so the answer for this question is the
term final is a predefined word in java
that is used while declaring values to
variables when a value is declared using
the final keyword then that particular
value of that particular variable will
remain constant throughout the execution
of program so sometimes if you include a
normal variable and provide an operation
on that particular variable then the
value of that particular variable will
change after the execution of program
but when you declare the same variable
using final keyword then no number of
operations or any kind of manipulations
applied onto that variable will not
change the value of that particular
variable so that's a specialty or final
keyword in java
so followed by that we'll dive into the
next question that is
what happens when the main method is not
declared as static
so the answer for this question is
when the main method is not declared a
static then the program may be compiled
perfectly but ends up with a serious
ambiguity and throws a runtime error
that says
no such method error
so when you basically declare a main
method don't forget to specify the
static keyword so with this we finish
the beginner segment of questions
followed by the beginners segment we
have the next segment that is the
intermediate level segment
so the first question in the
intermediate level is
what is jdk and mention the variance of
jdk
so the answer for this question is so
jdk is basically an abbreviation for
java development kit
this is a combined package of jre that
is the java runtime environment and
developer tools used for designing java
applications and applets
oracle has the following variants for
java development kit so the first one is
the jdk standard edition which is
normally used by beginners and
intermediate developers next after the
jdk standard edition we have the java
development kit for enterprise so this
particular enterprise edition is used by
professional java developers for
developing java based applications and
frameworks
now the last one is the java development
kit micro edition
now followed by 21st question we will
dive into the next question that says
brief access specifiers and types of
access specifiers in java so the answer
for this question is as follows
basically access specifiers are
predefined keywords used to help a java
virtual machine to understand the scope
of a particular data member or data
manipulating method within a class or
outside the class so in java we have
four types of access specifiers the
first one is public access specifier so
when you declare a data member or a data
manipulating method as public then that
particular data member or method can be
accessible by any class or object
throughout the package
followed by that we have the private
access specifier so unlike the public
access specifier when you provide the
private access specifier then the
accessibility of that particular private
data member or the data manipulating
method will be provided to specific
classes and specific objects only
and finally we have the protected access
specifier so the protected access
specifier is a bit more secure than the
private access specifier so the access
for this particular protected data
member or protected data manipulating
method could be a little more difficult
to access unless you are going to
implement everything which is present in
that particular package
so basically if you are trying to access
the protected data member or protected
data manipulating method
of a different package then you need to
first import the package into your
existing package so that's how the
protected access specifier works
practically so finally after the major
three axis specifiers we have the
default access specifier so default
access specifier will be provided by the
java virtual machine so in case if you
declare a variable or a data
manipulating method without using any
specific access specifiers that are
public private and protected then jvm
implicitly considers the default access
specifier so there is no much of a
difference between the public access
specifier and the default access
specifier both have the same
functionality and accessibility so
followed by this question we enter into
the next question that is
can a constructor return a value
so the answer for this question is as
follows
yes
a constructor can written a value it
basically returns the current instance
of a class implicitly you cannot make a
constructor written a value explicitly
but automatically it returns the
instance of a class
so the next question is explain this
keyword in java so in java we do have a
keyword which is called as this so what
does the keyword this mean in java is a
question
so the answer for this question is the
term this is a special keyword
designated as a reference variable so
the term this keyword is used to refer
to the current class properties like
data manipulating method instance data
member and constructors so followed by
the 24th question we have our next
question that says
explain
super keyword in java so the answer for
this question is as follows
the term super is a special keyboard
designated as a reference variable so
similar to this keyword even super
keyword acts as a reference variable but
the difference is super keyword is used
to refer to the immediate parent class
object so followed by the 25th question
we have our next question
that is explain method overloading in
java so basically method overloading and
method overriding etc are the concepts
of polymorphism so now let's have a
correct answer here
so the process of creating multiple
method signatures using one method name
is called as method overloading
so for example consider that you wanted
to include an addition operation in your
program that performs addition operation
so the first method will be having the
name add and inside the method
parameters you will be having two
integer types of parameters similarly
you wanted to perform another addition
operation with the same name add so here
you will provide the method name
completely same to the first method but
inside the parameters there is a
difference
you are adding
three parameters here
so when you pass the values to the add
method
then which method to be overloaded
that's the confusion right so should i
overload or should i execute the first
add method or the second method so this
completely depends on the number of
parameters you pass if you are passing
two parameters then the first method
will be executed if you are passing
three parameters then the second method
will be executed so this is how the
method overloading happens in java so
the process of method overloading can be
achieved by using two different ways the
first way is to change the number of
arguments so that's what exactly i've
discussed before now the second way is
varying the written type of the method
so with this let's enter into the next
question
can we overload a static method
so as discussed before the values of the
variables or data manipulating methods
will not be changed when we have used
the keyword static in front of it so the
question is can we overload a static
method
now let's discuss the answer for this
the answer is no java does not support
overloading of static method
the process worked through an error
reading static method cannot be
referenced so followed by this we have
our next question
so the next question is define
late binding the answer for this
question is
binding is a process of unifying the
method call with the methods code
segment late binding happens when the
methods code segment is unknown till the
method is called during the runtime
so followed by this we have our next
question define dynamic method dispatch
so the answer is the dynamic method
dispatch is a process where the method
call is executed during the runtime the
overridden method is called through a
reference variable of superclass so this
process is called as runtime
polymorphism
now we have our next question
why is delete function faster in linked
list than an array
so basically link list and array are the
java collections or in other words it's
also considered as data structure so to
answer this question you need to
understand the analogy of linked list
and array so basically an array is a
complete
memory block of consecutive memory
locations so consider that your memory
location starts from 100 and your array
has 10 locations so it's a complete
reserved block of from 100 101 102 to
1.9
so you have 10 memory blocks so in case
if you wanted to add a number or a
delete a number then you had to make
changes to the complete memory block but
when you come into linked list
you have
the memory blocks used from the memory
heap so basically what you do here is
you basically connect the nodes through
addresses
so in case if you wanted to eliminate a
number then what you do is just to
manipulate the addresses so the address
of the consecutive node will be changed
so that's the only change what you make
so now
this is the reason why the
delete function or any kind of
manipulation function is faster in
linked list compared to array
so now let's have a brief answer on this
delete function is faster in linked list
as the user needs to make a minor update
to the point of value so that the note
can point to the next successor in the
list
now followed by this we have our next
question
give a briefing on the life cycle of a
thread
so the life cycle of a thread includes
five stages which are as mentioned below
newly born state runnable state that is
it provides the jvm with a feedback that
i'm ready to run now followed by that
the running stage where the threat is
actually running followed by that the
block stage so basically the thread will
be blocked for some reasons for some
intermediate output or something if the
thread is waiting for an input from
another source or
something similar so that's where the
blocked state comes to existence and
finally the dead state once after
everything is processed the threat is
eliminated by gvm
now followed by this we have our next
question that says
explain the differences between
the operators provided here
so the operators might look similar but
they are different now let's understand
about these operators in a much better
way through the answer so the answer for
this question is although they look
similar but there's a huge difference
between them so the first operator which
looks like two greater than symbols
perform the operation of right shifting
so when you provide a binary number or
binary value then the bits will be
shifted towards the right and the second
symbol or the second operator which is
having three greater than symbols is
used to shift out the zero filled bits
so this is the functionality of these
two operators now followed by that let's
have the 33rd question
brief the life cycle of an applet so the
answer for this question is the life
cycle of an applet basically involves
the following stages the first stage is
the initialization stage next is the
start stage third is the stop stage
fourth is destroy and finally we have
paint
now the next question is
why are generics used in java
so the answer for this question is
compile time type safety is provided by
using generics in java so this approach
allows the users to catch unnecessary
invalid inputs at the time of
compilation
generic methods and classes help
programmers to specify a single method
declaration a set of related methods or
with a single class declaration a set of
related types
so followed by this we have our next
question
explain externalizable interface
so the answer for this question is the
externalizable interface helps with the
control over the process of
serialization the externalization
interface incorporates read external and
write external methods so we have
listened to a new term here which is
serialization so what exactly is
serialization
serialization is a process of sending
your java code or java project from one
computer system to a different computer
system so basically if you wanted to
execute some kind of java program from a
different location then you serialize
this particular code to a different
location where you actually want to
execute and this particular process of
transferring your code is called as
serialization
now the next question is explain daemon
thread so the answer for this question
is the daemon thread can be defined as a
thread with least responsibility the
daemon thread is designed to run in a
background during the process of garbage
collection in java
the set daemon method is used to create
the demon thread in java programming
language
so we have our next question now explain
the term enumeration in java
so the answer for this question is
enumeration or enum is an interface in
java enum allows the sequential access
of elements stored in a collection in
java now the next question is
why is java considered as a dynamic
programming language
so the answer for this question is java
was designed to adapt to an evolving
environment java programs include large
amount of runtime information that is
actually used to resolve access to the
objects in real time so this is a reason
why java is considered as dynamic
programming language
now followed by this we have our next
question
can you run a code before executing the
main method
so the answer for this question is
yes we can execute any code even before
the main method
we will be using the static block of
code in the class when creating the
objects at load time of the class any
statements within the static block of
the code will execute it once while
loading the class even before the
creation of objects in the main method
now the last question in the
intermediate section is how many times
the finalized method is called
so the answer for this question is the
finalized method is called by the
garbage collector so for every object
the garbage collector calls the finalize
method just for once
now with this let's enter the advanced
segment of interview questions based on
java
so the first question in the advanced
segment is
can the keywords this and super
be used together so the answer for this
question is
no
this and super keywords should be used
in the first statement in the class
constructor so the following code
segment will give you a better idea
so you can see that we have used the
keyword super and this in the class
constructor that is the first class
constructor
now this is how you can use super
keyword and this keyword together in
case if you wanted to use so with this
let's continue with the next question in
the advanced level
so the next question says explain jsp
page so the answer for this question is
jsp is basically an abbreviation for
java servlet page so the java servlet
page consists of two types of text the
first is the static data and the second
one is java servlet page elements
now the next question is
explain
jdbc so the answer is jdbc is an
abbreviation for java database connector
jdbc is an abstract layer used to
establish connectivity between any
existing database and to a java
application
next question is
explain the various directives of jsp
so the directives are instructions
processed by jsp engine
after the jsp page is compiled into a
servlet directives are used to set page
level instructions
insert data from external files and
specify custom tag libraries directives
are defined between the following
symbols
so these are the symbols that are used
to specify the directives in a jsp page
the different types of directives are
shown as below there are three types of
directives they are include directive
page directive and tagleb directive so
include directive includes a file and
merges the content of the file with the
current page
the page directive is used to define
specific attributes in the jsp page like
error page and buffer
the taglib directory is used to declare
a custom tag library which is used in
the jsp page
followed by that we have the next
question what are observer and
observable classes
so the answer for this question is
objects that subclass the observable
class maintain a list of observers when
an observable object is updated it
invokes the update method of each of the
observers to notify that the observers
that it has changed its state
the observer interface is implemented by
objects that observe observable objects
might be a little confusing but you need
to
read this answer once again you can
pause it and you can read this answer
once again so that you can get a brief
understanding of this
followed by that we have the next
question
what is session management in java so
the answer for this question is
a session is essentially defined as the
dynamic stage of a random conversation
between the client and the server the
essential communication channel includes
the string of responses and requests
from both sides typically the most
popular way of implementing session
management is the employment of a
session id in the communicative desk
course of the client and the server
the next question is brief about spring
framework spring framework is basically
the framework of frameworks now the
answer for this question is spring is
essentially defined as the application
framework and inversion of control
container for java basically the chief
purpose of spring framework is to create
enterprise applications in java
also it is especially useful to keep in
mind that the central features of the
spring framework are essentially
conductive to any java application
so the next question is explain jca in
java so the answer for this question is
jca is basically an abbreviation for
java cryptography architecture
so jca provides a platform that gives
architecture and apis for encryption as
well as decryption
jc is used by the developer to combine
the application with the security
measure it also helps in performing the
third-party security rules it uses the
hash table encryption message digest etc
to implement the security so the next
question is
explain
jpa in java so the answer for this
question is
jpa stands as an abbreviation for java
persistence api
the jpa is enabling us to create the
persistence layer for desktop and web
applications
jpa deals with the following
java persistence api query language java
persistence criteria api object mapping
metadata etc
so the last question in our list is
explain the different authentications in
java servlets
so the answer for this question is
authentication options available in
servlets are as follows the first one is
basic authentication so the basic
authentication consists of username and
password provided by the client to
authenticate as the user the second one
is form based authentication
in this particular type of
authentication the login form is made by
the programmer by using html
followed by that we have the third type
of authentication that is digest
authentication
digest authentication is similar to
basic authentication but in this the
passwords are encrypted using hash
formula
this makes digest more secured and
lastly we have the client certificate
authentication the client certificate
authentication requires that each client
accessing the resource has a certificate
that it sends to authenticate itself
this requires ssl protocol
today we are going to perform two
hands-on projects on covet data analysis
using python and tableau
this is going to be a really interesting
and fun session where i will be asking
you a few generic quiz questions related
to coronavirus please make sure to
answer them in the comment section of
the video we'll be happy to hear from
you covet or coronavirus is an ongoing
global pandemic of coronavirus disease
that emerged in 2019 and was first
identified in wuhan china
it is defined as an illness caused by a
novel coronavirus called severe acute
respiratory syndrome coronavirus 2
commonly known as sars cove 2
on march 11 2020 the who declared coven
19 a global health emergency the virus
has so far infected over 22 crore people
and killed more than 4.5 million
innocents
in india there have been over 3.3 crore
confirmed cases and nearly 4 lakh 41 000
deaths have been reported so far
this data is according to official
figures released by the union ministry
of health and family welfare
as the world tries to cope up with this
deadly virus we request all our viewers
and their family members to follow all
the necessary precautions to avoid
getting infected
quiz time
now let's see our first quiz in this
project
what does corona in corona virus mean
here are the options is it a beer
b respiratory is it c crown or is it d
sun
this is a very general question i am
sure a lot of you may already know some
of you may not
please let us know your answers in the
comment section of the video we'll be
glad to hear from you
now in this video we will use
three different kobe 19 data sets and
perform data analysis using python and
tableau
the project will give you hands-on
experience working on real-world data
sets and how you can use the different
python libraries to analyze and
visualize data and draw conclusions
you will learn how to create different
plots in tableau and then make a
dashboard from the visuals
the project will give you an idea about
the impact of coronavirus globally in
terms of confirmed cases deaths reported
the number of recoveries as well as
active cases
we will also see how india has been
affected since the pandemic started and
dive into the different states and union
territories to learn more about the
covet 19 influence and the vaccination
status
first let me show you the two data sets
that we'll be using
so for our first project using python
we'll be using the first two data sets
kovid 19 india and covet vaccine
statewide
let me open the two data sets
okay
so this is the first data set you can
see here we have
the date
we have the time
then we have the different state names
scroll down you can see we have kerala
tamil nadu delhi haryana rajasthan
then we have something called as
confirmed indian national so actually
this
two data sets confirmed indian national
and confirmed foreign national we won't
be using so in the demo itself we'll be
dropping these two columns
what we are concerned about are the last
three columns
the
cured cases or the recoveries
the number of deaths reported and then
we have the total number of confirmed
cases
let me just
sort the b column that is the date
column so that you have an idea
about the recent data we have
i'll continue with the current selection
and
sorted you can see here
this is
till
11th of august 2021
so this data was collected from kegel it
has some discrepancies that we will see
in the demo
the data is available for free we will
provide the link to the data sets in the
description of the video so please go
ahead and download them
the visualizations and results that you
will see in the demo are based on the
data sets that we'll be using we haven't
pre-processed the data to remove
outliers or any missing values
now before i jump into the demo let me
show you the second data set that we are
going to use
okay so covet wax in statewide is my
second data set let me open it
there you go
so
this is the second data set that we'll
be using in the python
project you can see we have a column
called updated on then we have the
state again you can see here there are a
few discrepancies here
it has taken the country name and not
the state name below you can see there
are the
different state names
and you can also see we have information
about the total doses administered
we have the sessions sites
first dose administered then we have the
second dose
then we have information about male and
female doses
you can see here the different
vaccines
administered covaxin and cova shield you
have sputnik v
and here are the different age groups as
well
and finally if you see we have
male individuals vaccinated the total
number of female individuals vaccinated
for a particular day
we have information about transgender
individuals vaccinated and finally we
have the total individuals vaccinated
each day
all right
before we jump into the hands-on part
let's have a look at the second quiz in
this project
so
here is the second quiz question which
is the first country to start covet
vaccination for toddlers
is it a japan b israel c portugal or is
it d cuba
this is a very recent development that
took place if you watch daily news
updates on coronavirus you'll be
definitely able to answer the question
please give it a try and put your
answers in the comment section of the
video it is really important for our
viewers to know the right answer
all right
so now let's begin
with our demo
so i am on my jupyter notebook
so the first project we are going to use
python jupyter notebook
i'll just
rename this notebook as
kovid data analysis
project
and click on rename
all right
so first and foremost
we need to import all the necessary
libraries that we are going to use so
first i am importing pandas as pd this
is for
data manipulation
then we have numpy as np
numpy is used for numerical computation
then we are importing
matplotlib c bond and plotly
these three libraries will be used for
plotting our data and creating
interesting visualizations finally i'm
also importing
my date time
function
all right
so i'll hit shift enter to run the first
cell
now it's time
to load our first data set
which is related to
the kovid 19 cases in india for the
different states and union territories
so i'll create a variable called covet
underscore df dfs for data frame
i'll use my pandas library
and then
give the read underscore csv function
since our data sets are
csv files
and inside
double quotes i will pass in the
location where my
data sets are present
so i'll just copy this location
i'll paste it here
we'll change
the backslash to forward slash
and after that i'm going to give my
file name followed by the extension of
the file
i'll say kobed19
india.csv
let's go ahead and run it
all right
now
to see the first few
rows
of the data frame i'm going to use the
head function
i'll say head and within
brackets let's say i
pass in 10 which means i want to see the
first 10 rows of data
if i run it there you go
here you can see from 0
till 9 so we have 10 rows of information
and these are the different
column names you have s number
date time state or union territory then
you have confirmed indian national
confirmed foreign national
cured cases debts reported and the
confirmed cases
all right
now moving ahead
let's use the
info function to get some idea about
a data set
if i run it you can see here
it gives us the
total number of columns we have nine
columns the total number of entries or
the rows we have eighteen thousand
hundred and ten rows of information
starting from zero till
eighteen thousand one hundred and nine
you see here the different types of
variables or column names that we have
then it has information about the memory
usage as well
and this side you can see
the data types
cool
now we'll use another very important
function which is
to get
some idea about statistical analysis the
basic statistics about your data set for
that i'll be using the describe function
okay
so if you can see here
the describe function is for
numerical columns only
and you have the measures such as count
the mean standard deviation
maximum minimum the
25th percentile 50th percentile and the
75th percentile value
okay now let's move ahead and import the
second data set
which is related to
vaccination
so i'll create a variable called vaccine
underscore df
i'll write pd dot
read underscore csv function which is
present in pandas
library i'll move to the top and i'll
copy the
file location
and we'll change the name of the file
copy this and
let me paste it here
and instead of covered underscore 19
underscore india
i'm going to say goverd
underscore
vaccine
underscore statewide
okay
so this is the data set that we saw
covered underscore vaccine underscore
state wise
all right let me run it
cool
and
let's display the first
seven rows of information from this data
frame
i'll be using the head function and
inside the function i'll pass in 7
there you go so here you can see we have
from 0 till 6
there are total
24 columns
a lot of them have null values you can
see here
all right
now
from the first data set which is the
kovid underscore df data frame
we'll be dropping a few
unnecessary
columns such as the time column
confirmed indian national and conformed
foreign national as well as the s number
we don't need these columns so it's
better
to learn how to drop the columns for our
analysis
so i'll say
kovid underscore df
dot
i'll use the
drop function
and within square brackets i'll pass in
the
column names the first is s number
i'll give a comma
within double quotes i'll say the next
column is time
my third column that i want to drop is
confirmed
indian national
give another comma
within double quotes i'll say
confirmed
foreign national
outside the
square brackets i'll give another comma
and pass in my next
argument
that is in place equal to i'll say true
i'll give another comma and say
access
equal to one
let's run it
okay it has thrown an error let's debug
the error
says confirmed indian okay it should be
indian national and not indian nation
i'll just
mention it as national will run it again
okay
now we have
removed these four columns
let me show you the data set now
there you go
so we have only the date column state or
union territory cured deaths and
confirmed
now
let's see how you can change the format
of the
date column for that you have the
function called to datetime
i'll say
covid underscore df
i'll pass in my column name that is date
i'll say equal to
pd dot
i'll use the pandas function that is 2
underscore
date time
i'll say covet underscore df which is my
data frame name
pass in my
variable which is date
give a comma
and i'll use my argument that is format
equal to
i'll say percentage y
give a dash say percentage
m
give another dash and say percentage d
let's run it
and i'll print
the head of the data frame
cool
now moving ahead
now we will see how to
find the total number of active cases
so active case is nothing but the total
number of confirmed cases minus the sum
of
cure cases plus that's reported
so let's
find the active cases i'll give a
comment
okay
i'll first write my
data frame name that is copied
underscore df
within square brackets i'll give my new
column which is active underscore
cases
i'll say equal to
[Music]
kuvit underscore df
and my first column would be
the confirmed cases column
minus
i'll say
kuvid underscore df
then i'll pass in my cured column
plus
i'll again say
koved
underscore df
and
add my
deaths column
this time let's print
the last
five rows from the new
data frame that we have created
okay
let's run it
it has thrown an error let's debug it
says
data frame object has no attribute tails
this should be
teal
there you go
you can see here we have added a new
column called active cases which is
the confirmed cases minus the sum of
cured and
reported column
now we will
learn how to create a pivot table using
the pandas
library
so in this table we'll be summing all
the
confirmed deaths and cured cases
for each of the states and union
territories
so we'll be using the pivot underscore
table function for this
i'll create a variable called statewise
and say pd dot
i'll use the pivot underscore table
function
i'll pass in my
data frame that is kovid underscore df
and then
i'll give my
values parameter
inside the square brackets i'll pass in
my
columns
confirmed
deaths
and then we'll have the
cured column
give a comma
and next argument would be index
which is going to be my state
slash
the union territory column
let me bring this to the next line so it
is more readable
i'll say union territory
i will
give a comma now
and pass in my last argument which is
agg
function that means aggregate function
and
this function would be max
all right
let's run it
okay
now
i'm going to find out the
recovery rate
so recovery rate is basically
the total number of qr cases divided by
the total number of confirmed cases into
hundred
so i'll say
statewise
and within
square brackets i'll
pass in my
variable that i want to create which is
recovery rate
this will be equal to
[Music]
the
cured cases
multiplied by 100
by the total number of
confirmed cases
within square brackets i'll give my
column as confirmed
let's run this
okay
i'll just copy this column
paste it here so this time we are going
to find out the mortality rate
so mortality rate is nothing but the
total number of deaths
divided by the total number of confirmed
cases into 100
so i am just going to
replace the names here i'll say
mortality
all right
and then instead of cured i'll say
my deaths column
in 200 divided by the
confirmed cases let's run it
okay
now
we are going to
sort the values
based on the confirmed cases column
and we'll sort it in descending order so
let me show you how to do it i'll say
statewise equal to
i'll use the function short underscore
values
so
i'll pass in my variable statewise dot
and use the
short underscore
values function i'll say by
i want to sort it by my confirmed
cases column
give a comma and i'll say
ascending
equal to
false
let's run it
now we are going to plot our pivot table
using a nice
visual
so for that i'm going to use
my
background underscore gradient function
and inside that function we'll pass in
our cmap parameter
i'll show you how to do it
say style dot
background
underscore
gradient
and inside this we'll pass in a
parameter called c-map
so c-map stands for color maps this is
present inside the matplotlib library so
here you can see there is a nice
documentation on choosing color maps in
matplotlib
this is provided by matplotlib.org
if i scroll down you can see there are
a number of c maps that you can use
purples blues
you have something called reds
there are other things like magma you
have summer autumn spring winter
cool
all these
you can use whichever color map that you
want and here you can see the different
shades
or the gradients
okay
so i'm going to use
my color map as cube helix
let me run it and show you the
pivot table
there you go
here you can see we have our pivot table
ready
now as i said in the beginning there are
a few
discrepancies in the data set so here
you can see
there's one called maharashtra and
there's also maharashtra triple star
this you can ignore even if i scroll
down you have madhya pradesh followed by
three asterisks you can ignore this
value as well even for bihar we have
so these have been duplicated
and
here you can see the different
state names and union directories then
on the top you have the confirmed cases
cured cases
the debts reported and the new
columns that we created
these are calculated columns recovery
rate and mortality rate
and we have ordered it in
descending order of confirmed cases so
so far
our data says that maharashtra has the
highest number of cases followed by
kerala karnataka tamil nadu andhra
pradesh and uttar prades so these are
the top
five states which have the highest
number of
confirmed cases
even if you see the mortality rate is
also high for maharashtra
and
if i scroll down
the mortality rate is also high for
uttarakhand if you see here
if i scroll further
your punjab the mortality rate is also
high
all
right so this was our first
visual that we created in the
govi data analysis project
now moving ahead
we'll see the
top 10 states based on the number of
active cases
so we'll start
i'll give a comment top 10
active
cases
states okay
so
we are going to explore another very
important pandas function in this which
is known as group by
so i'll first
pass in my data frame which is kovid
underscore df
dot followed by the group by function
i am going to group my data based on
state slash
union territory column
then i'll say
dot
max which is to find the
maximum value from the states
that have
the highest
active cases so i have passed in my
active cases column
and
we're also going to group it
based on the date column
after that
we are going to sort the values so i'll
use my function that is sort
underscore values
i'll say
short by
my column that is
active cases
let me bring this to the next line
underscore
cases
give a comma and say
ascending equal to
false
say dot
and then
reset my index
for that i'll use reset underscore index
function
okay
let's check if everything is fine
i have
missed a square bracket here let me give
another square bracket here
okay
and all this we are going to store
in our
variable called top underscore 10
underscore active
underscore cases
okay
now let me go ahead and
run this cell
okay there is
a syntax error here
now let's run it okay
now i'll create another variable called
fig
here we'll pass in
the plt which is for matplotlib
library
and we'll give the
figure size
using the
fig size
argument
it's equal to and within a tuple and
passing the size let's say 16 comma 9
we'll run it
okay
and
let's give
a title to our plot so here we are going
to create a
bar plot
so
using plt.title we'll pass in the
title let's say top 10 states
with
most
active cases in india
i'll give a comma and pass in the size
of my title
let's say 25
okay you can see we are slowly
being able to
create our graph
the most important thing is to pass in
the
x-axis and the y-axis
i'll say ax which is for axis
to pass in the axis i am going to use
the bar plot function that is present
inside the c-bond library
i'll say sns.bar plot
i'll say data equal to
my
variable which is top underscore 10
underscore
states
this is actually active states
all right
and now
i'm going to use the
ilock
function
and
take the first 10 states so i'm using a
colon and then giving 10 as my value
iloc is for index location
i'll give a comma and say my
y-axis to be
active cases
give another comma and say my x-axis to
be
state
slash
union territory
give another comma
we are going to pass in the line width
to 2
i'll say line width equal to 2
and will give
an edge color
let's say the edge color is
red
okay
so i have my
access defined now
let's run it
there's an error here it says stopped in
active states not found
let's go to the stop and see the exact
okay so this is
top 10 active cases let me change it to
cases here
now run it
okay the x axis also has a mistake this
should be
state slash union territory
now let me run it
there you go we have our
plot
created but as you can see here the
labels of the
different states and union territories
are overlapping so for that
let me first pass in the
x labels i'll say plt.x
label
and my
x label would be states
then i'll say
plt dot
by label
my y label will have the total
active cases
and finally i'll write plt dot show
before i run it let's collate all the
lines of code that we have written for
our
top 10 states for most active cases in
india into one cell
so what i'll do is i'll just copy this
and we'll keep
adding
in this cell itself
okay
i'll go to the top
next we'll copy
my figure size
and we'll
paste it here
next let's take the
title
and put it here
give us peace
and we are going to copy
the cell
and i'll paste it here
all right
now it's time to run it
there you go
you see it here
we have a nice
bar plot ready on the top you can see
the title top 10 states with most active
cases
and you see the edges are in red color
for all the bars
on the x axis you have the different
state names maharashtra karnataka kerala
you also have andhra pradesh gujarat
west bengal and chhattisgard
so as you can see
maharashtra
has the
highest number of active cases based on
our data followed by karnataka caroline
tamilnadu at second third and fourth
place respectively
and
the ninth place we have west bengal in
the tenth place we have chattisgarh
on the y axis you can see the total
active cases
which are
in lakhs
okay now moving ahead now we'll see the
top 10 states based on the total number
of
deaths reported
so i'll give a comment
top states
with
highest
debts
okay
so i'll first
create my variable
saying top 10 underscore
deaths
this will be very similar to
what we did here
just that we need to change a few
column names so instead of active cases
we'll be using depths
okay
so i'll start with my
data frame that is covered underscore df
followed by
using the
group by function and i want to group my
data
based on
the state slash
union territory column
then i'll choose the max function
and within
double square brackets i'll pass in
my column names deaths and date
let's make it consistent i'll be using
single quotes
okay
i'll say dot
i'm gonna
sort my
result therefore i'm using the sort
underscore values function
i want to sort it by
deaths column
i'll give another comma and say
ascending equal to false which means i
want to
order my result in
descending order
then i'll say dot reset underscore index
okay
after that i'll give my
figure size i'll say plt dot figure
and within brackets i'll pass in my
argument which is
fig size
equal to
using a tuple i'll say 18 comma let's
say 5
now let's give a title for that i'll use
the title function which is present in
the matplotlib library
i'll say
top 10 states with
most
deaths
and let's give a size to the title 25
now it's time for us to give the access
labels we'll just scroll down
okay
so i'll say ax equal to
again this will be a bar plot so i am
using my c bond library followed by the
bar plot function
my data will be top
underscore 10 underscore depths
which is this variable
i'll give
my index location iloc
i'm going to choose
12 states the reason being
there are some discrepancies in the data
i'll show you once i plot this result
so in the y-axis we'll have
deaths column
in the x-axis we'll take
state
slash
union territory
okay
i'll give another comma
and say
line width
equal to 2
and will give
an edge color to our
bars like we did here
so i'll say edge color
equal to let's say
black
okay
now
finally we'll give
the x label the y label
so i'll say plt dot x label
x label would be states
my y label
will be
total
death cases
then i'll write plt dot show
now let's run it
there you go
you can see here we have a nice bar plot
on the top we have the title top 10
states with most deaths
now
what i specifically wanted you to
see was these discrepancies in the data
you can see here maharashtra is repeated
twice even
in our data that we collected from kegel
karnataka
spelling has an error you can see here
we have a few
rows of information where karnataka is
spelled as
k a r a a n instead of k a r n a
all right so to
remove
these
two results or to ignore these two
results i had given
my index location till 12 so we have
maharashtra karnataka tamil nadu delhi
pradesh west bengal kerala punjab andhra
pradesh and satis curd
with the states that have the most
number of deaths reported
okay
now we'll create a line plot to see
the
growth or the trend of active cases for
top five states with most number of
confirmed cases so the states are
maharashtra karnataka kerala tamil nadu
and uttar pradesh i can show you
so these are the states with
highest number of active cases
okay
i'll just give a comment saying
growth
trend
all right
so for that
we'll start with our
figure size as
plt dot figure
i'll use my parameter fixed size equal
to
12 comma 6
i'll say
my axis as sns dot
this time we are going to create a line
plot
my data would be
the original data frame that is covered
underscore df
and
within square brackets i'll say coverage
underscore df
and we are going to pass in the
state or the union
territory column
i'll give
a dot and use the
isin function
so the
states should include
maharashtra
will give a comma the next state should
be
karnataka
next
we have
kerala
give another comma
my fourth state is tamilnadu
give a comma
and my fifth state would be
uttar pradesh
all right
so i'll give
a comma here and then say
x equal to
the
date column
y
will be
active cases column
and i'm going to use another parameter
called hue which is to
give different colors to the different
states the five states that we are
looking for
so hue
will be my
state slash
union territory column
okay
after this
i'll say
ax
dot set title
my title will be top 5
affected
states
in india
we'll give a size let's say
16
all right okay this should be size equal
to 16
and
to make sure everything is fine let me
just
move it to the above line
okay
now we'll run it
okay there is some error again
it says
invalid syntax let's see where we went
wrong
let me bring this to the above line
okay this should be covered underscore
df
okay
make sure you
keep these small errors in check
let's try and run it again
all right
if i scroll down
there you go here you can see we have
the top five affected states in india
you see the
different
states here and the colors so
this violet or the purple color is for
maharashtra you can see
how the
active
cases searched around
april and may
and then you can see
even for karnataka the active cases
surged very rapidly
around may
and june
then it has decreased luckily
similarly you can see the plots for even
uttar pradesh
as well as for tamil nadu so all the
five states you can see one common trend
that
after
march so around april
the cases started to emerge very rapidly
and
later after july they started dipping
okay
now
we are going to use our second data set
which is related to vaccination
all right
so first and foremost let me go ahead
and
print the data frame for you
so that you know
the data that we are going to use so
this is the data we are going to use
for our next
set of analysis
even this data has a few errors and you
can see there are a lot of missing
values it makes sense because not all
the days you would have
vaccination
for people
and
very crucial
error that we are going to deal with is
this
state column here you can see
in the state column we have india in
a few rows so we are going to ignore
these rows
all right
first let's rename
our updated on column to just
vaccine date
so
you can use the
rename function present in the pandas
library to do it
so i'll say vaccine underscore df dot
rename
i'll say columns equal to
within
curly braces
i'll write
updated
on
which is my
original column name
give a colon i want to change this to
vaccine underscore date
i'll give a comma
and say in place equal to true
so it will change
my
column name from updated on to vaccine
underscore date
in the
original data frame
let's run it now
let me go ahead and print
the first
10 rows
in the data set
you can see here we have successfully
changed
the column name to vaccine underscore
date the rest of the columns remain the
same
all right
now you can
check
the
total number of
columns
rows
the data types and the memory usage
using the info function
here you can see it
we have total 24 columns
7845 entries
and these are the
columns that are present
and if i scroll further
you see here
sees
the memory usage and here on the right
you can see the
data type
cool
now as you saw
the data has a lot of missing values
let's find the sum of all the missing
values for each column
so i'll save action underscore df dot is
null
and then i'm going to use the sum
function over it
if i run it
there you go so almost
all the columns have
missing values but columns such as
male individuals vaccinated female
individuals vaccinated even for columns
like
the age groups there are a lot of
missing values
now in the next step we are going to
drop a few
missing value columns
so i'll say
a new variable called vaccination
i'll give the data frame name vaccine
underscore df and use the drop function
and inside the drop function we are
going to write
columns equal to
i'll pass in the
column names that i want to drop
i'll say
doses
administered
so this is the column that i want to
delete sputnik v doses administered
i'll give a comma
the second column is e e
f i
the next column is
18 to 44
years
within bracket
it has doses
administered
give a comma
i'll say 45 to
60
years
doses
administered
give another comma
the final column that we are going to
drop is
60 plus which is this one 60 plus years
deuces
administered
okay
so these are the columns that we want to
drop
and finally i'll give my parameter
access equal to 1
okay let me just recheck this
column names first one is sputnik v
doses administer then we have
efi
followed by
18 to 44 years doses administered then
we have 45 to 60 years doses
administered
finally we have 60 plus years
i have added
a s here which was missing and there
should be a space as well
because there's a space here in the
column now let's run it
all right
so we have successfully dropped
the columns that we wanted to drop
now i'll say vaccination dot head
you can see here
we have dropped those columns and we are
left with these columns now
okay
now
we are going to create a
plot
that is a pie plot to see
the vaccination for male and
female individuals so i'll give a
comment
as male versus
female vaccination
to create this pie plot i am going to
use the plotly library that we had
imported which is this one plotly
okay
so first of all we need to filter out
the
male individuals
from our data frame
i'll say male equal to
vaccination
meal
and passing in the column
individuals
vaccinated
we need to recheck the variable name
whether it is correct or not
you see here male
individuals vaccinated
then i'll say
dot
sum
similarly will filter out the female
individuals
i'll say female equal to
vaccination
which is my new data frame
within square brackets i'll pass in the
column name female
individual
vaccinated
i'll say dot sum
okay
okay these should be individuals as per
the
column name present in the data frame
cool
now i'm going to say px dot pi function
which is present in the plotly library
i am going to
give the names of the
pies
so first one is meal
and the second one is
female
give a comma and say
values
equal to
meal comma
female
then i'll give a comma and pass in my
title which is
male and
female vaccination
okay
this should be names
all right now let's go ahead and run
this cell
it will take some time to create the
pie chart here we go
see here i have my title male and female
vaccination
so these are the two
pies or the areas
you have the label female and the value
here you have the label meal and the
value
so from our data you can see 53 percent
male
individuals have been vaccinated
compared to 47 percent for female
okay now we are going to drop all those
rows where
our state was mentioned as india in the
original data set
i had shown this to you in the beginning
so we are going to remove
rows
where
state is india
okay
so to do that i'll say
vaccine i'm creating another variable
called vaccine
and
we'll use our original data frame that
we had
imported which is faction underscore df
i'll say
vaccine underscore
df
dot
state
not equal to
india
now let's
print vaccine
okay you can see here we have our
data frame printed and from this data
frame we are taking only those values
or the rows where state is not equal to
india
cool
now what we are going to do is
we will rename the last column which is
total individuals vaccinated to
just total
so i'll say vaccine dot
rename
we'll use the parameter columns equal to
within
curly braces i'll say
total
individuals
vaccinated
give a colon
and we'll change this to just total
give a comma and say in place equal to
true
and finally i'll print my
head of the new data frame
this should be columns equal to
okay
now you can see here if i scroll to the
right and if i check
we have successfully renamed our column
all right
now moving on to the last two
visualizations that we'll see in this
first project using python that is to
find the states with most number of
vaccinated individuals and the state
with the least number of vaccinated
individuals
okay
just give a comment
most
vaccinated
state
okay
for this i'll first create a variable
called wax underscore
vac which is for maximum vaccination
i'm going to use my
data frame vaccine
followed by the group by function
i want to grip it by state column
and
we'll find the total sum
of vaccinated individuals
for each state
i'll convert this to frame
there should be a dot
to underscore frame
and i'll pass in my column name which is
total
after that
i'll say max underscore vac
equal
to
max underscore vac dot
short
underscore values
i'm going to sort it by
my total column
and say ascending equal to false which
means i want to sort it in descending
order
so that we have the
states with the
highest number of
individuals vaccinated
i want the top 5 states
now
let's go ahead and
print it
so this will create a nice table for us
there you go
here you can see
we have maharashtra uttar pradesh
rajasthan gujarat in west bengal as the
top five states with most number of
vaccinated individuals
now we are going to use this table and
convert it into a
chart
now i had already written my
code for the
bar plot i'm just going to paste it
so here i have defined my
figure size as ten comma five
then i'm giving a title as top five
vaccinated states in india and the size
is 20
after that i have created a variable
called x
which is going to store my bar plot
this bar plot we have created using the
c bond library
and
you see here i have my
y axis defined
then
i have the line width and the edge color
as well i've given my x label as states
by label as vaccination and i'm finally
going to display my plot so let's go
ahead and run it
okay you can see it here
we have converted this
table into a bar plot now
so first we have maharashtra with the
highest
number of vaccination
then we have uttaprades rajasthan
gujarat and west bengal
now
i want
the viewers
watching this video to
find the states with least number of
vaccinated individuals and convert that
table into a
bar plot that will show the bottom five
vaccinated states in india which means
the states which have
least number of individuals vaccinated
so please go ahead and put your
codes in the comment section of the
video it will be very similar to these
two cells just that now we want to know
the least five vaccinated states in
india
so please put the code snippets in the
comments section of this video we'll be
more than happy to know from you in case
you are not able to do it will
definitely keep the answers in the
comments itself
all right
so this brings us to the end of the
first
project on kovit data analysis using
python
so
in this project we used two data sets
one was on
the covet 19
india data set for different states and
union territories and the second data
set that we used was for
analyzing the status of vaccination in
the different states in india
now we'll move on to our second project
okay so before moving on to our tableau
project let's see the final quiz
which of the following is not a common
coronavirus symptom so this question is
to make you aware of the correct coveted
symptoms
here are the options
is it a fever
b
vision loss c loss of taste and smell or
is it d curve
please put your answers in the comment
section of the video and let us know
what you think
now we'll move on to our second covet
data analysis project
for this project we'll be using
the tableau software and a global
coronavirus data set first we look at
the data set and the fields we have
okay so i am in my data set folder
we have already seen the first two data
sets in our
python project
this time we are going to use the global
covet data let me open it
all right so here you can see
we have the different country names
there are
192 countries in our data set
let me go to the top
so
we have
country or region
we also have the code
for each of the countries
then we have column called last updated
so here you can see our data is still
12th of march 2021
and there are two columns which
don't have any information that is
people hospitalized and people
tested then we have a column called
active cases then we have a column for
confirmed cases
in the different
countries we have the number of deaths
and then we have the incident rate
the latitude and the longitude for the
countries
then we have the mortality rate
this is in fractions
then we have the number of
recovered cases and finally we have a
column called uid
so we'll be mostly using the country
column
active
confirmed deaths
and the recovered cases column
and we'll be using the tableau software
to create interesting visualizations and
we'll convert those visuals and put it
in the form of a dashboard
towards the end of the project
okay so let me
close this file or let it be open
i'll search for tableau public
you can see here i have
tableau public installed
you can use the
desktop version of tableau or the public
version of tableau
so for this project we are going to use
the tableau
public edition
so here you can see i have
created a few visuals already
if you want you can clear them out
okay
now
the first thing we need to do is to
connect our csv data set to tableau for
that
under connect
we have to a file
i'm going to use
text file
and under
chrome downloads i'll search for my
folder
covered
india
and here i have my
global covet data file let me open
it this will take some time to load
that you can see
so on the tableau you can see the view
here
it shows the country or the region
you have the last update
you have columns like active confirmed
deaths
mortality rate and recovered
and here you can see the
symbols for the
different columns so this is
a globe which means this field
is a
region or a
geographic field
abc means it's a text field then we have
the calendar which is for a date field
abcr
text field and this
hash represents numeric fields
all right
so now that we have loaded our data
let me just click on sheet1
so this is the canvas where we are going
to
create our different
reports
all right
so on the left you can see there are two
panes the data pane and the analytics
pane
in the data pane you can see the
name of the data set global covet data
and here you can see the
different columns that we have in the
data set so on the top
the ones marked in
blue are called as dimensions
and at the bottom
whatever you see
are marked in green and are called as
measures
so
dimensions are always represented with
blue icons and measures are in green
icons
so
tableau has automatically detected the
different
data types for each of the
columns all right
so
first of all we are going to create a
simple table
to see the total number of
confirmed cases for each of the
countries
so for that i'm going to drag my country
or the region column onto
rows
here you have rows i'll just drag it and
drop it here
there you go it has populated all my
country names starting from afghanistan
till
jimbah way so it has ordered in
ascending order of alphabets
now to
see the total confirmed cases for each
country i am going to drag my confirmed
column onto text
so here under marks card you have
the text option i'll just drag it
and drop it here
there you go
so tableau how easily has
shown me a table where you can see the
different country names and on the right
you have the total number of cases that
have emerged
from these countries
now this is not the most recent data as
i
told you this data was till march 2021
cool
now you can go ahead and
short the
table based on the
total confirmed cases here on the top
you can see here
there are two options to sort in
ascending order or in descending order
let's first sort in
ascending order
by sum of confirmed cases within country
and region
there you go so here you can see these
are the countries which have very
few cases
and if i scroll down
you have france uk russia brazil india
and us with the highest number of
coveted 19 cases
if you want you can also
short it in
descending order so that the countries
with the highest number of confirmed
cases appear at the top
you can see it here
and these are the countries that have
very few covet cases
now you can convert this simple table
into different charts and graphs
to do that
here on the
right top corner you have an option
called show me
now
i can just click on
this horizontal bar graph
so that will automatically convert my
table into a bar graph
again you can go ahead and
short the data
there you go
so here you have u.s india brazil russia
uk france spain and italy this is a
horizontal bar graph
sorted in
descending order of confirmed cases
now suppose you want to display only the
top few countries with the highest
number of confirmed cases for that you
can select these bars
so i'll select till let's say
germany
or let's say till argentina
okay and i'll click on keep only you can
see it here it says 12 items selected
that is the sum of confirmed cases i'll
just click on keep only
there you go so
this horizontal bar graph has
information only for these
few countries that have the highest
number of confirmed cases
now you can go ahead and
play with the color formatting
so here under colors let me choose
a green color
okay
now you can mark here since we selected
only the top 12 countries with the
highest number of confirmed cases so
what we did was we just filtered it to
the top 12 countries so tableau has
automatically added country region in
the
filters card
now if you want you can go ahead and
edit this filter as well
suppose you want to remove argentina you
can just uncheck this click on apply and
ok you see here argentina has been
removed i click on
undo so ctrl z to get it back cool
now you can convert this
horizontal bar plot into a vertical bar
plot let me show you how to do it i'll
just remove these
fields from my
chart
now what i'm going to do is i'll
drag country or region onto columns
and i'll have
confirmed
column under rows
there you go here you can see we have
a vertical bar plot now
and again you can
use the axis now to short your data this
is in
descending order similarly you can sort
it in ascending order here you have the
option to
sort your data
okay
cool
and below you can see the
different country names
all right now you can go ahead and
give
a name to this sheet
let's say
top 10
confirmed
countries
to supply
and click on ok you have the title to
this plot
similarly you can change it here as well
top 10
confirmed
countries
okay
now let's move on to our second
visualization where we will create a
global map so this global map will show
the different countries
present
in the map and the cases that they have
so to create the map first i'll drag my
longitude
generated
field onto columns and then i'll drag
latitude on to rows
you see here we have the map ready and
now
i'll drag
country
region onto detail
so this will give you
the different country names you can see
here we have canada
the united states
mexico
here you have india
sri lanka
there's australia
this is brazil
and similarly we have spain france
belgium
there's italy here you have also greece
similarly we have the african countries
like
central african republic this congo
angola
and on the top you have russia and this
is iceland so on and so forth
now
i'm going to drag
the
active cases column onto
detail again
now if i hover the cursor you can see
the
active numbers for brazil you can see
for india
you have
countries like china
then here you have thailand
algeria
now
i'm going to
drag the confirmed cases column on to
label
so that you have the labels here you can
see here the confirmed labels
cool
now if you only want to focus on a few
countries
present in a particular region you can
highlight that region for example
suppose
for europe you want to focus on this
region if you select it it will
highlight only those countries and if
you hover your mouse over these points
it will show you the active cases and
the total number of confirmed cases
all right now if you want you can go
ahead and change the color of the
circles let's see i'll keep it as
red
okay
so this is how you can create a
map to represent the different active
and
confirmed cases
i'll rename the title to
global
cases
i just click on apply and ok
similarly i'll change the sheet name as
well to
global cases
okay
now from this map you can see the
countries such as usa
brazil
you have russia
and india with the
highest number of kovit 19 cases even in
countries such as
spain the numbers are
really high
and
a lot of the african countries were also
impacted
and these small countries like solomon
islands you have
fizzy islands
with few number of cases even for new
zealand as well
all right
now moving to our next
visual
now we are going to see the top 10
countries where highest debts have been
reported so far due to the pandemic for
this we will create a tree map now
so first of all i'll
choose my country column and
put it under
columns
and then i'll select
the depths column and put it under rows
i have the
bar plot ready
next i'll go to show me and here i have
the option to select a tree map
you see here for a tree map you need one
or more dimensions and one or two
measures so i'll just click on this tree
map
okay here you can see i have my tree map
ready so tableau has automatically
adjusted my fields so it has removed my
fields from rows and columns and put it
under size color and
label
next i will drag my
country column and put it under filters
and from here i'm going to choose top
i'll filter by field i'm going to select
the top 10
countries
based on the total number of
deaths
just click on apply and click on ok
so
these are the countries us brazil mexico
india united kingdom italy russia spain
france germany
which have the highest number of deaths
reported
now
you can also
give the label
i'll
put the deaths column under label so
that you have the labels here
all right so this was a tree map that we
created to show the
top 10 countries with the highest
number of deaths
i'll just
change the title top
10 depth
cases
now you can also edit the title in terms
of the font color and everything
that's i'll keep it tableau bold
and i'll choose this as 14 click on
apply and ok
there you go
similarly let's
rename the sheet to
death cases
cool
now moving
to the next visualization
where we'll see
about the recoveries
so before we move on to
create a visualization for the
top 10 or let's say the bottom 10
countries in terms of recoveries let me
show you how to change the
color of the stream app
so here
by default tableau select the automatic
palette
if you want you can change it to
different
palettes let's see i'll go with
gold purple diverging
click on apply and i'll click on ok
this is not looking
that great you can select another one
let's say
red green white diverging
cool
now let's
go to our
fourth visualization which is about
top 10
recoveries
i'll click on apply and ok
first i'll drag my country or the region
column
under
columns
and then i'll take
the recovered column under rows
this time
instead of
sum
we are going to choose
average
okay
and here
i'll select
my packed
bubble chart
after that i am going to drag my country
or region onto
colors
and then i'll also
put country under filters
so i'll go to
the top
menu
and i'll filter it by field
i want to show the top 10 countries
based on the average number of
recoveries
if i click on apply and ok
and see here these are the countries
that have
the highest number of
average recoveries you have india brazil
turkey italy argentina germany colombia
russia poland and mexico
i'll just rename this sheet to
recovery cases
cool
now let's move on to our next visual
okay
so here we are going to create a scatter
plot to analyze the total confirmed
cases versus the total number of deaths
so whenever you have two numeric fields
it is better to create a scatter plot to
visualize the
cases
so for that i am going to
drag my conformed
cases to columns and then i'll drag
my
depths column onto rows
okay
so by default
the shape is a circle
and
to see all the countries i'm going to
drag country under color
i'll say add all members
there you go
here
you can see the legend for the different
countries
and
the top you have
us with the highest number of confirmed
cases and the highest number of
deaths as per our data set then you also
have brazil here which has the
second highest number of deaths
then you have
mexico followed by india
so this data is not a very recent data
this data was last updated on
march
now from this we are going to filter out
the top 10 countries with the highest
number of
confirmed cases
and the deaths
so for that i'll drag my country column
onto filters
and i'll go to top
filter by field
i'll say top 10
and i'll click on apply and okay
so here you can see we have siberia
sweden
belgium
netherlands
spain
italy france
russia
uk and
you have brazil
so these are the countries which have
the
highest number of
active cases
so instead of active let's select deaths
click on apply and okay
okay
now if you see we have us here
brazil india
then mexico
uk
russia france
italy germany and spain which have the
highest number of deaths reported so far
now if you want you can
change
the
size of the circles based on the
highest number of active cases so i can
just drag my active column under size
so you can see here
spain
france
uk have the highest number of active
cases
let's say instead of active i'll just
have
my confirmed cases under size
okay
and then
you can also change the shape from
circle to
any other shape let's say square or
this asterix
okay
let's go with the triangle
cool
i'll rename this sheet to
confirmed versus
deaths
click on apply and ok
i'll rename this to
confirmed
versus
deaths all right
now moving on to our
next visualization where we will see
the mortality
for each of the countries
and figure out which countries have the
highest
mortality rate
okay
so
first i'll drag
mortality rate
onto
column
and then i'll have
my
country column under rows
so there you go now let me go ahead and
sort it in
descending order
so you can see here you have yemen
there is mexico syria sudan egypt
equator china and other countries which
have the highest mortality rate
and you can also
select the country
region under colors
let's go ahead and edit the
color
instead of automatic let's select summer
or
you can go for some other palette let's
say
tableau
classic medium i'll assign this palette
yes i'll apply and okay
all right
finally
we'll
move ahead to our
last visualization where we'll create a
dual access chart
so the dual axis chart in tableau will
have one column and two different
visualizations on the rows so here you
have
one
column and on the right also you'll have
one column with their own access values
so this dual access chart will be for
recovered cases and the
death cases
let me show you how to do it
so i'll drag
my country
field onto
columns
and then
i'll choose
recovered column onto
rows
so here i have got my
line chart
and the second
column i'm going to choose is the depths
column
i'll hold my
cursor and i'll place it
when i get this
green color
rectangle i'll place it here
there you go
so now we have created two measure names
deaths and
recovered
and here you have the access values you
can synchronize the access values if you
want
the recovered cases are in millions and
the debts are in thousands
now let's go ahead and
change
the
recovered line to
bars
and
we're going to short it
okay
now let's change the color
we'll select let's say
blue
i'll assign the palette click on apply
and okay
and if you want you can also change the
color
for
deaths from blue to let's say
winter i'll assign the palette click on
apply and okay
you can have whichever color you want
and to make the access seam you can just
right click on this axis and click on
synchronize access
so here you can see the values
let's keep it in thousands only
cool
i'll rename this sheet to
dual access
okay
now before we move ahead and create our
final dashboard i want to show you
one more
feature in tableau that is to format the
labels so you can see here
instead of writing 5 lakh 30 821 we can
change this in terms of millions or
thousands and write it as let's say 530k
to do that
what i'll do is i'll go to format and
here we have the option
to select
font
and in font i'll go to fields and
click on sum of depths
and here
in this pane
i'll choose
number custom
decimal places will be zero
and
display units i'll select
thousands
you can see here the values have been
changed to 531k 193k 158k
so on and so forth
cool
now let's go ahead and create our final
dashboard here is the option to create a
new dashboard so i'll just click on
new dashboard
and we are going to increase the
size here so that
it fits our
view
so we have selected the default view and
the size i am going to
choose here is automatic so now we can
drop our sheets one by one
first let's drag the
global cases
sheet here
okay you can see we have our map
now
i'm going to choose the top 10 confirmed
cases
all right
and after that we'll choose the
death cases sheet so tableau will prompt
you to place the sheet
at the right location
okay
and now i'll choose my
fifth visual which is confirmed versus
deaths
and if you want you can choose any one
of
these let's say i'll take the dual axis
chart
now you can just
minimize the
sheets and adjust the
sizes to
make it look better
okay
so you can see here we have our
dashboard ready now you can still
go ahead and customize the dashboards in
terms of adding different
filters to it we are not going to
show that now you are getting some
messages here two are known for nulls
you
can
remove them as well
and here on the top you have the option
to
click on the presentation mode
there you go so this is our final
dashboard that we have created
all right so this brings us to the end
of the
second
coronavirus data analysis project using
tableau
now you can just click on escape to go
back
all right now you can save this
and
this will be published in the
tableau public platform under your
profile
so that brings us to the end of this
video tutorial on covet data analysis
project using python and tableau welcome
to this exciting video on olympics
dataset analysis using python by
simplyloan
this is going to be a very interesting
and interactive session where i'll give
you a brief about the history of
olympics and throw some light into the
recently held tokyo olympics
but we'll focus more on using olympics
dataset that is available on kegel and
perform some exploratory data analysis
you will understand how to use different
functions in python to analyze and
extract meaningful information
during the course of our discussion i'll
be asking you a few general questions
related to the olympics try to answer
them in the comment section of the video
so let's begin
the olympics is one of the biggest
sporting events on the planet
it is held every four years
the first modern olympics took place in
athens greece in 1896.
as per national geographic
the original olympics took place in 776
bc
so they began as part of an ancient
greek festival with celebrated jews the
greek god of sky and weather
the rings in the olympics logo represent
the five continents europe africa asia
the americas and usuria
from 1924 to 1992 the winter and the
summer olympics took place in the same
year but now they alternate every two
years
before i move on here is an interesting
question for you
only two people have ever won gold
medals at both the summer and the winter
olympics
who are those two people
please share your answers in the
comments section of the video we would
like to know from you
the summer olympics in tokyo began on
the 23rd of july and recently concluded
on the 8th of august
we got to witness some thriller matches
that went down to the wire some amazing
victories and sadly there were a lot of
heartbreaks as well
winning and losing are part and parcel
of any game
fans across the world were really happy
to see this global event happen this
year following last year's postponement
due to the coronavirus pandemic
with our olympic fever high let's take
this opportunity to work around a
project to perform exploratory data
analysis using python to analyze and
visualize past olympics data and answer
specific questions
in this video we will be using specific
python libraries such as numpy pandas
matplotlib and cbond to make sense of
our data and extract meaningful
information
we are going to visualize our results
with different charts and graphs
before i show you the data set that we
are going to use for our analysis
i have another general question for you
which is the first olympics where all
the participating countries sent female
athletes i repeat which is the first
olympics where all the participating
countries sent female athletes
put the year and the city name where the
olympics was held in the comments
section of the video we'll be more than
happy to hear from you
now let me go ahead and show you the
data sets that we'll be using in this
video
so here you can see i have my
olympics data set folder that has two
datasets these are csv files one is
called the athlete underscore events and
the other one is called noc underscore
regions
so
we'll be using these two data sets these
data sets can be downloaded from kegel
we will post the data set links in the
description of the video please go ahead
and download them these datasets have
been directly taken from the internet
now i'll show you the data sets
so this is my first data set you can see
on the top athlete underscore events
so i have
around
15 columns you can see the count here
and there are
nearly
2 lakh 71 116 rows of information
so this is a huge data set that we are
going to use
the other data set we are going
to use in this demo is called noc
underscore regions now here one thing to
note is
noc stands for national olympic
committee this is a three letter code
that is given by the olympic committee
we have the region names so afg is for
afghanistan you have alb for albania elg
for algeria we have also a column called
nodes you find some
notes about the
region for example here antiqua is
actually antiqua and
barbuda
all right
let's move to the
first data set that i showed you
this is our primary data set for our
demo
so these data sets have been directly
taken from the internet and were not
validated so the results that you will
see in the demo is purely based on the
data that we have collected
so the file athlete underscore
events.csv contains
nearly 2 lakhs 71 116 rows of
information and there are 15 columns
so each row corresponds to an individual
athlete competing in an individual
olympic event
so here id is actually a unique number
for each athlete then we have the name
which is basically the athlete's name we
have the sex or the gender which is male
or f for female
then we have the age of the athlete
which is in terms of integers
we have the height in
centimeters of the athletes then we have
the weight in kilograms we have the team
name these are the country names you
have china denmark netherland there are
around 200 country names
then we have the noc as i said noc
is a three letter code that stands for
national
olympic committee
we have the games this games contains
the year and the season you can see here
1992 summer you also have the winter
olympic information
all right
then we have a specific year column
to
tell you in which year this event had
occurred
now the year column is also an integer
column
we have the season so whether it was
summer olympics or winter olympics
then we have the city name this is the
host city
then we have the sport name you can see
here we have basketball judo football
tug of war
speed skating
there are so many
then we have another column called event
which is the complete even name as you
can see the sport name is basketball but
the even name is basketball men's
basketball to be very specific
again for speed skating you have
different categories like women's
thousand meters 500 meters
all right
now the final column is the middle
column so it has
the information about the athlete
whether
the athlete had won a medal be it gold
silver branch and na means the athlete
did not win any medals so we'll use
these two data sets
now let's
get started with the demo
we'll be using jupyter notebook for our
analysis so i'll take you to my jupyter
notebook right away
i've opened it on chrome so this is my
jupyter notebook that we are going to
use you can see here olympics data set
analysis
i have already
have a few cells that have been filled
with some piece of code
and you can see there are
some comments written as well we are
going to use this data set
so let's get started
first and foremost we'll import the
datasets so we are going to use
numpy pandas matplotlib and cbon
let me hit shift enter to import all the
libraries
all right
now the next thing is to load the
datasets
using
pandas read underscore csv function
so
i'll create a variable called athletes
i'll say equal to
pd dot i'll use the read underscore csv
function
and inside this function will give the
location
of the files so i'll copy this location
and here i'll paste
make sure this is within
quotations
and these are all
forward slash
i'll give another forward slash
and after that i'll give the
file name that is
athlete
underscore
evens
dot csv
i'll close the quotation
let's run it
okay
similarly we will load the second data
set i will create another variable
called regions
so it will have my data frame
i'll use the same function pd dot read
underscore csv
i'll just copy this
file path
till here
we paste it
and
i'll give my second file name which is
noc
underscore
regions dot csv
you can verify here
the first one is athlete underscore
events the second one is noc underscore
regions
okay i'll close the quotation and we'll
run it again
okay there seems to be some error i
think this is the regions
cool
now moving ahead
let's see the
first few rows of both the data sets
i'll use the head function for that
i'll say
athletes dot head
so this will print the first
five rows
from my data set
athletes you can see here
from zero to four you have five rows of
information the id name sex or the
gender
each height weight
if i go to the right you have games year
season sport event and medal
now let's see
the
second data set that we
imported or loaded
i'll say regions dot head
it says
regions
is not defined
let me cross check it
okay i have taken it as region let's
make it regions
cool
now let's run it there you go so these
are the first five rows from our second
data set you have noc region and some
nodes
all right
now the next step is to combine
both the data sets so we'll join the
data frames using the pandas merge
function
let me show you how to do it so this is
going to be a horizontal join
i'll create a variable
called athletes underscore df
then
i'll use my first variable which is
athletes
i'll say dot merge which is my function
name
i'm going to merge
the regions data frame
i'll use the how parameter
in how i'll give my value as
i want to do a left join
and my common column in both the data
sets is actually noc
so i'm going to use
the noc column as my common column to
merge both the data sets
now let's go ahead and
print the
most data frame i'll say athletes
underscore df.head
let's run it
there you go
so
if you see clearly if i move to the
right you can see here we have added two
more columns that were present in the
second data set which was regions so we
have regions and nodes
added to my
first data set that is
athletes underscore
events
cool
now one thing to note here is
see the column names are not consistent
if you see here the rest of the columns
start with a capital letter but if you
see the last two columns that we just
added now start with the lowercase
letters so we'll use
the rename
function to make the column names
consistent
but before that
let's
see the
shape of the data frame so i'll print
the shape of the data frame to know the
total number of rows and columns
i'll say
athletes if i hit tab
you will see it will give me
the prompt i'll select athletes
underscore df
i'll use the
shape attribute
let's run it
and see the result you can see here it
gives me the total number of rows so 2
lakh 71 116 rows and earlier we had
15 columns in the first data set and now
that we have added two more columns so
the total number of columns becomes
17 now
cool
so now it's time to make the
column names consistent
so i'll show you how to do it i'll say
athletes underscore
df
dot i'll use the rename function
and then i'll say
columns
equal to
i'll use curly braces
my first column
that is region i want to change it to
a region but the r should be capital now
or upper case
we'll give a comma
and then say
my second column
this should be
a region actually
my second column that is notes
i want to
change the first letter to uppercase so
i'll say capital n
the rest all remains same
we'll give a comma here
and say
in place equal to true
so it will change
the column names and will
reflect in this athletes underscore df
data frame
let's run it
now to verify you can again use the head
function i'll run this again
let me scroll down and move to the right
you can see the difference there you go
so we have successfully renamed the last
two columns region and notes
all right
now moving ahead
now
i'll show you how you can use the info
method to print information about a data
frame including the index data type the
column data types
normal values and memory usage
so for that you just need to use the
info function so i'll write
athletes underscore df
dot info
let's run it there you go so here we
have the
data columns you can see total
17 columns you have 2 lakhs
716 rows or entries
then you have the
different column names and
you see it says
null and the data type of the column
below you can see some information about
the memory usage
alright
next
the describe method is used for
calculating statistical information such
as mean standard deviation the
percentiles of the numerical values of
the data frame and much more
it analyzes both numeric and object
series and also the data frame column
sets of mixed data types
so let me show you how using
the describe function you can display
some statistical summary
i'll just write
describe
and
give parenthesis let's run it
okay if i scroll down
you can see here
by default
the describe function will only give
information about numerical columns so
here you can see we have the total count
the mean of each of these columns you
have the standard deviation the minimum
and maximum value and then we have the
25th percentile the 50th percentile and
the 75th percentile value of the columns
id age height weight and year
all right
now one thing to notice here is if you
see the year column
the minimum year is 1896
so this is when olympics started
and until recently
the rio olympics that was held in 2016.
all right
now moving ahead
now let's check if there are any null
values present in the columns of the
data set
so first i am going to create
a variable called
nan values
give equal to i'll say athletes
underscore df
and the function to check is i'll say is
an a
i'll create another
variable called nan underscore
columns
and here i'll use the any function i'll
say nan underscore
this
variable which is underscore values
dot i'll see any
and i'll print
my nan columns variable
so this will display the result in terms
of
boolean values so if there are any null
or any n or missing values in any of the
columns it will say true otherwise it
will say false
let's display the result
there you go
so if you mark here clearly
so there are
nearly six columns where we have missing
values you have
age height wheat metal region and notes
columns that have
missing values so hence
it has given us true the rest of the
columns do not have any any n or missing
values hence they are false
all right
let me scroll down
now
let's see the total number of null
values for the
above
six columns
so i'll say
athletes
underscore df
dot
i'll use the function is null
and again i'll use this sum function
okay this should be is null
if i run it
you can see it here
so our age column has
9474
rows where we have null values
then we have
some null values for the height column
as well for the weight column so these
are the total number of
rows where we don't have
any information regarding each height
weight or region
notes this medal is
self-explanatory because a lot of the
athletes who participate in olympics
don't win any medals so for them
the value is any now before i move ahead
i have a question for
you people so the question is i want you
to print the column names containing
null values or missing values in the
form of a list
so
please answer this question and put it
in the comments section of the video we
would be happy to
know your approach
so the question i'll repeat it again i
want you people to print the column
names containing null values or missing
values in the form of a list
so basically
on the top we saw there were
six columns that had
null values i want you to print these
six
columns in the form of a list
all right now moving ahead
now let's see the data for specific
countries
let's say you want to see the athletes
who have participated in the olympic
games from the beginning for india
for that you can filter your result
using a function called query
so let me show you how to do it i'll say
athletes
underscore df
dot
will use the query function
and then
i'll say
team
which is my column name
should be equal to equal to
and the value i'll give us india
now let's
display the first
five
rows of information
or the details for the athletes who are
from india if i run this
okay there is some error here
okay so we need to make sure this entire
expression or the condition should be
within
single quote i'll just
delete this single quote from here and
we'll add it in the end
now let's
run it there you go
so here you can see we have
the top five rows
of
the athletes who are from india you can
see here the region is india you can see
the noc is india the team is india
and
let me go to the left you can see the
name of the athlete
the sex each
so for each you have some missing values
you have to wait
team year and everything
all right
similarly you can also check for
japan let me just copy the
above code
i'll paste it here
and instead of india i'll say
japan
i'll run it
there you go
so if you see here
you can see all the details are for the
athletes who are from japan
all right
moving ahead
now i want to know the top 10 countries
who have participated since the
inception of olympics in
1896
so for that i'll create a variable
called top underscore 10 underscore
countries
say equal to
i'll use my data frame that is
athletes underscore
df
i'll say dot
team
then i'll use the function
value underscore
counts
i'm going to
sort
my count
in ascending order
just mark the way in which i am writing
the functions
any error in terms of syntax or the flow
will
throw you an error
i want to display the top 10 countries
now let's go ahead and
print it i'll say
top underscore 10 underscore countries
all right
let me run it
okay it has given us an error let's
debug it
okay so this should be
value
counts and not count
let's run it again
another error
okay
so this should be short underscore
values and not value
let's run it again
there you go
so here you can see the top 10 countries
participating in olympics since
1896 you have united states then we have
france so these are the number of
participants who have taken part
since 1896
so the most number of participants have
come from us then we have france great
britain italy germany canada japan
sweden
we also have australia and hungary
i'll scroll down
now we are going to convert this table
that we got or the output that we got
in the form of a graph
so i am trying to create a bar plot to
plot the
top 10 countries were participated in
olympics so here i am using the
figure function to give the figure size
so these are the dimensions 12 comma 6.
now i'll tell you what this plt x text
means just wait for a while
i have given a
title to my plot saying overall
participation by country
and then
using the c-bond library and the bar
plot function
i am plotting the
x
and the
y axis so my x axis has top
i should make this top 10 countries
because above we used top underscore 10
underscore countries similarly for
y-axis i'll make it top underscore 10
underscore countries and then i'm using
a color palette called set 2.
let's run it there you go so if i scroll
down you can see here we have a nice
bar plot
this is a vertical bar plot
and here you can see the bars which
represent the different country names
first we have united states which has
the highest participation since the
beginning of the olympics then we have
france great britain italy germany
canada
and we have the rest of the countries
cool
now moving ahead
the next visualization we are going to
see is the age distribution of the
athletes
so for this we are going to create a
histogram
i'll be using the matplotlib library
specifically for this visualization
so i'll say plt dot figure
will give the figure size using the
argument fig size
equal to
and this will be a tuple actually
my size is going to be 12 comma 6
i'll say
plt
dot
title
now you can give
any title that you want i'll say
age
distribution
of the
athletes
then we'll also give the x labels i'll
say plt dot
x
label this will have each
then we see plt dot
y label
and this will have
the label as number of participants
next
i'm going to use the hist function so
i'll say plt.test
and
i'll pass in my data frame that is
athletes
underscore df
dot
age
which is my column name
comma
i'm going to pass in the
bins
for that i'm going to use the np dot
e-range function so mp is for numpy
and inside this i'll say
10 comma
80 comma
2
so my bins will start from the value 10
and go until 80 with a size of 2
comma
i'll give another parameter that is
going to specify the color of the bins i
want my color to be
orange
and then
i'll use
the edge color to separate the bins
lch color this is the
parameter or the argument name and the
color i want is white
let's give a
semicolon here and this should be edge
color there's a spelling mistake here
now let's run it and we'll see the
output
so there you go
so this is a nice
histogram that shows the distribution of
the
age of the athletes you can see the
title each distribution of the athletes
on the y-axis you have the number of
participants on the x-axis we have the
age values ranging from
10 to 80 with a size of
two
and if you say this
we have
most number of athletes
who have a age between
20 to 30 you can see here
so early 20s we have maximum number of
athletes participating in the olympics
we also have a few athletes who are
beyond 40 years of age you can see here
we have a
few athletes
even closer to 60 also
and similarly we have a few athletes who
are under 18 years of age
all right
now you can see here the bins we had
taken orange color so our all the
bars are represented in orange color
and the edge you can see here we have
the white color
all right
now moving ahead
now in the initial slides of the video
we discussed the summer and winter
olympic games let's look at the
different sporting events that are part
of the summer and winter olympic games
just to give you a heads up the winter
olympic games are held once every four
years for sports practiced on snow and
ice
so here
i have my variable name winter
underscore sports so i am extracting
for season equal to equal to
winter and i am going to display only
the unique values now let me run this
cell
okay so you can see here these are the
different winter sports that are
held
during the winter olympics now similarly
let's see for
summer olympics so what i'm going to do
here is i'll just copy this
cell of code and will edit the
variables i'll say summer
underscore sports
athletes underscore df remains the same
here season will change it to
summer
dot sport dot unique remains the same
and
here i'll say summer underscore sports
that should be small
now let's run it
there you go
so here you can see we have
more number of olympic sports that are
held during the summer olympics compared
to
winter olympics
so these are the sports that are played
on snow and ice
and these are the sports that are played
during
summer
moving ahead
now it's time to analyze the total
number of male and female participants
who have taken part in different games
since 1896 till 2016 rio olympics
all right
so i'll say
gender
underscore counts which is my variable
name
i'll use my
data frame that is
athletes underscore df
dot
my variable name that is sex
dot value underscore
counts
and then we are going to print
gender underscore counts
let's run this there you go
so since the inception of olympics
we have more number of male participants
than
female participants
now here in this current cell you can
see we are trying to plot a
pie chart for male and female athletes
so i have given my figure size then i
have my title as gender distribution i
am using the matplotlib library and the
pi function
i am using the variable gender counts
that we used here
then i am giving my labels as gender
underscore counts dot index now i am
using this auto pct
the auto pct parameter enables you to
display the percent
value using python string formatting so
this is my string formatting that i have
used and i'm
initialized my start angle for the pie
chart as 150 degrees and i'm also giving
shadow to my pie chart so i have
written shadow equal to true
let's run it
all right so you can see here this is my
pie chart that shows you the
distribution of the
male and female participation
so for meal it is 72.5 percent for
female so far it is
27.5 percent as per the data set that we
have
now you can change this start angle to
let's say 180 degree
and it will
change the pie chart to this direction
cool
now moving ahead
this time
we're going to find the total number of
medals that the athletes have won
so i'll use my
data frame athletes underscore df dot
and then my column that is
middle i'll say dot value
underscore counts
let's run it there you go so you can see
the gold medals the bronze medals and
the silver medals are very much
similar to each other the numbers are
pretty much the same
all right
now it's time to focus on the total
female athletes who have taken part in
each
olympics
so i'll create a variable
called
female underscore
participants
i'll say equal to and then use my data
frame name that is athletes underscore
df
using
square brackets
i'll say
athletes
underscore df
dot
the gender should be equal to equal to
female
and
i'll use ampersand
i'll say
just copy this
paste it here
lc dot
season
equal to equal to we'll check for summer
olympics
and i want to extract only
the gender column so here it is sex
comma
my year column which is here
okay
and then
i'll say
female underscore
participants
equal to
i'll just copy this
paste it here
and then i'll use the group by function
say group by which is part of the pandas
library
i'll say year
and then i want to find the count
i'll reset the index
say reset underscore
index
is a function
and finally we are going to print
female underscore
participants and let's say the head
all right
so what we are trying to do is i am
trying to filter
my data only for the female athletes
for summer olympics
and here
i am printing
the participation
based on each year so i am finding out
the count
so here we need to add
one more square bracket
all right
now we'll
run it and see the result
the yuko
so you can see here from 1900 1904
all these years you can see the female
participation
let me change it to tail so that we have
the recent data of the
olympics
you can see it here for the beijing
olympics
5816
women athletes participated in 2012
london olympics we had
5815 olympics similarly for
the 2016 rio olympics we had
more participation than the london
olympics so
6223
women athletes had participated
all right
now here
this is another way in which you can
filter your
data for female athletes so i'm
using two parameters my gender should be
equal to female and season
is summer olympics let me just run it i
have stood it in a variable called women
olympics
now
here i am trying to
find a
count plot or i am trying to create a
count plot using my c bond sns library
i have set my style to dark grid
then my figure size i have given as
20 comma 10
my count plot will have the x axis
as year
the data is women olympics
and palette i am using as spectral
and then i have given a title women
participation
let's run and see the output
there you go if i scroll down you can
see on the top i have the title for my
count plot which says
women participation and on the y-axis i
have the count
and at the bottom you can see the
different year values from 1900 till
2016
and 2016 had the highest number of
female participation
cool
let me scroll down so in this cell of
code we are trying to plot a line graph
let me run it and show you the output
so this line graph shows the trend
which says plot for female athletes over
time
so here you can see the line graph so
gradually
the women participation has increased in
olympics since
its inception
there was a slight decrease here this is
around
1950s
and again that you can see here there's
a decrease with the women participation
in 1980 but since then since 1980 there
has been continuous
increase in the participation of female
athlete numbers
cool now coming to the next section
of our analysis
now we are going to filter the data to
see the details of the athletes who have
won gold medals
so
i'll create a variable called gold
medals
it's equal to i'll use my
data frame is
athletes underscore df
and
within parenthesis i'll use my data
frame name
which is
athletes
underscore
df
dot
i'll use the condition middle equal to
equal to
and my value would be gold
next
i'm going to
say
gold medals dot head
let's run it
there you go
so here
we have the
top five rows of the athletes who have
won
a gold medal you can see
all the
records have medal as gold
now we are going to use this
subset
of the data and perform some more
analysis
so here
i want to take only the values that are
different from nan so i'm going to use
is
finite
function and inside that i have said
gold medals each
let me just run it cool
now i want to see
the athletes who have
secured a gold medal beyond the age of
60 years
which is very rare
so we'll see the total number of
athletes with more than 60 years of each
having won a gold medal
so here i'm going to say
gold medals
i'll use my
as id
and then
i'll use
my variable
gold medals
and then
i'll say
age
should be
greater than
60
and then
close my square bracket and say count
okay let me just verify if everything is
fine
yeah
i'll run it
and we'll see the result so there are
total
six athletes who have won a gold medal
having aged more than 60 years
cool
now let me check
for which
sport
these six gold medals have come
so i'll say
sporting underscore event
this is going to be my variable name
equal to
i'll use the
same variable name gold medals
i'll going to choose
my support column
and then
i'll give my
condition
age
greater than
60.
now let's go ahead and
we'll print
the variable spotting event
if i run this you can see it here
so
for art competitions
even for archery and suiting and this
one called rook
we have had gold medals from athletes
who had an age
more than 60 years
now we are going to plot
this result or the table that we
achieved on the top
so i'll say plt dot
figure
i'll give my
figure size
equal to let's say 10 comma 5
then
i'll say plt dot
we'll use the
tight layout
say tight underscore
layout
then i'm going to use the c bond library
and
create a count plot
for my variable
sporting underscore
event
then i'll say plt dot
title
i'll give the title as
gold medals
for
athletes
over
60 years of age
let's run it
and if i scroll down you can see here we
have a nice count plot i have my title
gold medals for athletes over 60 years
and since
for archery we had
three players who secured a gold medal
having an age more than
60 years
you can see here archery is three at
competition one
rock is one and shooting we had
one medal
all right
now
we'll see the total gold medals
from each country
so for that
i'll say
gold
medals
dot
will use the
a region column
and
followed by that i'll use the
value underscore
counts function
and
i'll reset the index
with
name
equal to i'll provide the
middle column
then we are going to print the
head for the top five
countries let me run it you can see it
here
so
usa
has secured the most number of gold
medals then we have russia germany uk
and then we have italy
cool
now in this cell i am going to create a
plot to
visualize the table that i got
above
so i've used my labels my titles i am
using the cat plot function that is
present in the c bond library i have my
x axis my y axis the data which is total
gold medals
let me just verify
okay
and we'll run it
if i scroll down
you can see this is a different palette
that i had used which is a rocket
and you can see
usa has got the
most number of gold medals then we have
russia germany uk
italy and france now we also have
included france here which was not
present in this table the reason being i
have used head as six
so it will give me the top six countries
all right
now we will analyze
and look at the data for the most recent
olympic event that is present in our
data set i'm talking about the 2016 rio
summer olympics
so first of all i'll create a variable
called max year
which will be equal to my data frame
name athletes underscore df
my column name here and i'll use the max
function
then
let's go ahead and print my max here
i'll just show you the output you can
see here my max here present in the data
set is 2016 the rio olympics
next
we will
create another variable called team
underscore names
that will be equal to
my
data frame name athletes underscore df
within square brackets i'll give
parenthesis and then say
athletes underscore df
dot
year
should be
equal to equal to
my
output that is max here
which is actually 2016.
and then i'll say
ampersand
i'll just copy this
we'll paste it here
this time i'll use the
middle column and c equal to equal to
gold
i'll say dot
team
then i'll say team
underscore names dot
value
underscore
counts
dot head
and will display the
top
10
countries
let me run this
there you go so in geo olympics
united states secured the
most number of gold medals
now the reason this is 137 is we have
also counted
the team events for example basketball
similarly great britain had 64 gold
medals in total
russia 50 we have brazil 34 argentina 21
france 20 and japan
17. all right
now
using the above result we are going to
create a bar plot i'll just change the
steam underscore list to team underscore
names
similarly here also i'll make the
corrections as
team underscore names
cool
now we'll run it
and you can see here we have a nice
horizontal
bar plot so we have united states at the
top
great britain russia germany china
brazil
so here i am displaying the top
20 nations since i have used head
as 20.
so these are the top 20 nations who
secured the
most number of gold medals in the u
olympics
all right
now in the final section of this video
we will create a scatter plot to
visualize the height and weight of male
and female athletes who have won a medal
now it can be a gold medal a silver
medal or a bronze medal
but before that
we
need to filter the data only for
athletes who have won a medal now if you
had noticed here our
medals column also had a few
null values so we are not going to
consider
those null values here
we are only going to consider for the
athletes who have
verna medal
so for that i will create a
variable called not underscore null
underscore
medals
equal to i'll say
athletes underscore
df
then
i'll give my
let's make it df
i'll give my condition
let me just copy this
i'll paste it here
and then
i'll give my condition
height
and use the
not
null
function
and then i'll say
ampersand
create another parenthesis i'll say
athletes underscore df
this time we'll consider the
weight column
again i'll use the function as not null
and
i'll close the parenthesis
okay i had missed one s here cool
let me just run it now
all right
now we are going to create our final
plot i'll say plt dot figure
i'll give my
figure size
equal to
i'll say 12 comma 10
i'll say
access
equal to
sns dot
we'll be creating a scatter plot to plot
the
height and weight of the athletes who
have won a medal
i'll say scatter plot in my x-axis i'll
have
height
comma
in my y-axis i'll have
weight
comma
my data should be
not underscore null underscore
medals
so this is what we created here not
underscore null underscore medals
comma
i'll use hue equal to my
sex column
cool
finally i'll say plt dot i'll give a
title to my plot
saying
height
versus
weight
of
olympic
medalist
cool
now let's see our scatter plot
this might take some time to
keep the result because there are so
many athletes present in a data set who
have won a medal and also we are
filtering
in terms of
hue which is for male and female
there you go
so if i scroll down you can see here we
have a nice scatter plot
on the top you have the title of the
plot saying height versus wheat of
olympic medalist you can see
our age as the hue
so blue points are for the male athletes
and orange points are for the female
athletes
and on the y-axis we have the weight in
terms of
kilograms and you have the height in
terms of centimeters
cool
so that brings us to the end of this
demo session on
olympics
data set analysis
so we used two data sets to
[Music]
carry out this exploratory data analysis
and we
created some
visualizations to analyze and visualize
the data
all right
so that brings us to the end of this
video tutorial on olympics data set
analysis
indian premier league that is ipl is one
of the most popular and exciting events
in world cricket
ipl 2022 will begin on 26th of march so
it's the best time for us and our
viewers to learn about how to perform
exploratory data analysis using the
recently held ipl auction data set
so in this video all the results and
insights that you will see are totally
based on the data we have collected from
kegel we will leave a link to the
dataset in the description of the video
you can go ahead and download it
for this demo we'll be using python and
jupyter notebook to answer special
questions
so let's get started we'll move over to
our jupyter notebook
okay so i am on my jupyter notebook and
this is the file that we are going to
use so here you can see i have
some of the cells already filled in
so this will save us some time and we
can
explore this data set in depth so this
is the file that i'll be using or the
ipython notebook
cool
so first let's go ahead and import all
the crucial libraries that will be
needed for our analysis
so here you can see i'm importing the
pandas library the numpy library these
are for data manipulation and numerical
computation then we have c bond and
matplotlib for data visualization
then
i have imported this warnings
module
so that we do not get any warnings while
running the
code cool
so let me just hit shift enter to run
the first cell so here we will import
all the libraries okay it's done
now the next step is i'm going to create
a data frame in the name of ipl
and here i'm importing the data set
using the read underscore csb function
which is part of the pandas library so
pd here has been imported as pandas i am
giving the
data set location followed by the name
of the data set so here the name is ipl
underscore 2022 underscore dataset dot
csv is the extension of the file
so let me go ahead and run this as well
all right so now we have
successfully imported or loaded our data
set
now the next step let's go ahead and
explore our
data set so i'll use the head function
for this
ipl dot head
okay so here you can see the different
columns we have
an unnamed column which is actually
unnecessary for our analysis so we'll
see how to drop this column apart from
that we have the name of the players the
base price at which the
player was sold or whether the player
was a draft pick so here rashid khan
from afghanistan hardik pandya then we
have subman gill these are all
draft pick and then we have the
price at which
the players were listed in the ipl
auction then we have the type of player
whether the player is a bowler an
all-rounder a batchman
or
a wicketkeeper
then we have the cost in rupees this is
in crores so basically this column tells
us the
price at which the player was sold in
the auction
then we have the price or the cost in
dollars
after that we have
2021 squad basically
this means
in last year's ipl where was the player
so here you can see rasith khan was
playing
for srh the sunrises hyderabad in 2021
but this year in 2022 he'll be playing
for
gujarat titans similarly hardik pandya
was playing for mumbai indians for past
few seasons including 2021 but this
season is going to play for gujarat
titans
so on and so forth
now
let's see the total number of players
that are present in the data set and the
total columns that are there for this
i'm going to use
the shape attribute so i'll write ipl
dot shape you can see here there are
total 633 players that were part of the
auction and this includes the players
who were draft pick also
and there are total
eight columns in my data frame ipl
next
let's use the info function to check the
columns the data types and the total
non-null objects so i'll say
ipl dot info which is a function so i
have to use
brackets
there you go so here you can see it
saves total 633 entries from 0 to 632
data columns you have total 8 columns
and then these are the
different
column names and
here you can see the total normal
objects
present in the
column
and here you can see the data types
and at the bottom you can see the
memory usage as well
cool
now
the dot columns attribute will return
the name of the columns in the
data set so if i say ipl dot columns and
run it it will give me
all the different column names that are
present in the data frame
now as i said
the first column which is unnamed
colon 0 is
actually unnecessary so we are going to
drop it for that
we are going to use the
dot drop function and then i have passed
in my
column name followed by the axis on
which axis is it there
and then i say in place equal to true
which means it will
replace
and permanently remove
the unnamed column from the data frame
so let's run it and now we'll again
check
the head of the data frame you can see
before we had the unnamed column which
was the first column in the data frame
and now we have successfully removed it
so player becomes the first column in
the data frame
all right
now moving ahead
let's see the total number of null
values that are present in each column
of the data set so i'll say
ipl dot i'm going to use the is null
function
followed by this sum function
if i run this you can see here
the player column doesn't have any null
values similarly base price and type
column also don't have any null values
but you can see cost and rupees and
cost in dollars have
nearly 396
missing or null values the reason being
those players were not
picked in the
ipl auction and hence there was no price
associated
and then you can see there were a few
players who were not part of the ipl
squad in 2021
so
those are being reflected as null as
well
now we'll check the
rows that have
cost in dollar as null or nan so here i
have
used ipl and after that i am passing in
the column name which is cost in dollars
and then i have used the is null
function
if i run this
you can
notice the
cost in
dollars column all these values are nan
or
null
and even the same
rows have
any n for cost in rupees as well
cool
now the
next task is to
fill these
null values or any values with
zeros so for that i'm going to use the
fill any function and here i have passed
in zero so all the null values in the
data set will be replaced with zero
for
cost in
rupees column and
cost in dollars column
let me just run it
all right
okay
now
we will see the players who were unsold
in the 2021 auction which means
we will check the rows that have null
values for the 2021 squad column
so what i'll do is i'll say
ipl
within
square brackets i'll say ipl and then
i'll pass in my
column name which is 2021
squad
and then after this i'll say dot is null
so
this
cell
will give us
the unsold players in the 2021 auction
if i run this
you see here
you mark the 2021 squad column all these
players were unsold or did not
participate so hence it has nan values
all right
now what we are going to do is
we will replace all the null values
that are present in the
2021 score column with
not participated
like how we did in the previous example
we replaced all the null values with
zero here we'll replace with
a text value called not participated so
i'll say ipl
i'll pass in my column name which is
2021 squad
equal to
i'll say
ipl
2021
squad
dot
fill
any
which is the function and here i'll pass
in a
text or a string saying not
participated
all right
let's run it
before that let me just scroll it down
now i'll run it cool
now that we have treated the null value
successfully let's verify it again
so i'll just say ipl
dot
is null
and then i am going to use this sum
function
if i run this
okay this is also a function cool now if
you see we have successfully removed all
the null values and replaced with either
zeros or not participated and hence now
you can see none of the
columns in the ipl data frame have null
values so it shows zero
great
now moving ahead
now we are going to add another column
called
status
which will hold two values sold and
unsold
but before that
we are going to
slice
our data frame so here i am looking for
all the rows where
cost and rupees
is greater than
0
and those should be unique and
i am storing the value in a variable
called teams so here you can see we have
the different teams where the
cost in rupees is greater than zero
now
i am going to create
another
column called status so i have written
ipl
within square brackets i am passing in
the column name which is status and
that will be equal to
the team
replaced by
sold value
let me just run it and show you the
result there you go
so here you can see we have added a new
column called status and it has values
sold
and unsold
if i just say ipl
at the bottom you can see
the unsold values as well
cool
now in the next cell
we are going to check for duplicated
players so there are duplicate rows in
the data frame but here the names of the
players are same but in reality the
players are different
so
it is quite understood that
different players can have the same name
so
to get those names i am using the
duplicated function and i'll say keep
equal to false which means i don't want
to keep those players
now let's run it
there you go so here you can see
lalitha we have
two entries so lalitha dev here is an
all-rounder whose base price was 20 lakh
for 2022 ipl
and
last year
he was playing for the delhi capitals
and this year also
he is
sold
to delhi capitals
next we have
lalitha
who happens to be a bowler so this is
again different lalitha
so last year
he was unsold and even this year he
remains unsold
similarly we have amit mishra
who earlier used to play with the delhi
capitals but this time he remains unsold
so on and so forth so you can see two
entries for subham shrink as well and
shivam mishra
all right
now
let's answer a very basic question
we are going to
find out how many players
have participated
in the 2022 ipl auction
for that we have already seen
the total number of rows that were
present but again i am going to use the
shape function and within
square brackets i am going to say 0
which means it will give me the total
number of rows
and you can see
633 players were part of the auction
this is as per our data that we have
collected from kegel
up next we are going to find
how many types of players have
participated
so i am going to say
types equal to
say ipl
i'll use the column name which is type
and i'm going to find the
count of
each type of players that are present in
the data frame
i'm going to use the values underscore
counts function
and then i will say
type
dot
reset underscore index
if i run it
okay there is an error here let me
debug the error
okay so this should be value underscore
counts and
the variable name is types and not type
so let's run it
you can see here
we have the different types of players
so all rounders there are total 242 all
rounders who are part of the auction
then we have 215 bowlers 112 batsmen's
and 64 wicket keepers
now using the above table that we just
created
i'm going to
plot my first
pie chart
so for that i'm going to use the
matplotlib pi function so plt dot pi
i'm using
types dot values since i want
only the values from this table
and then
i'm saying labels equal to types dot
index
i've used a label distance of 1.2 to
maintain some space
and then this is my format in which i
want to
print or show or display the percentage
of
distribution
i am going to use shadow so it says
shadow equal to true which is another
parameter or an argument and then i am
going to start my angle at 60 degrees
and here i have used a title called role
of players participated
that will have a font size of 15 and
finally i am saying plt dot plot
so let me just run it
there you go so here we have a nice
pie chart or a pie plot so you can see
the different pies here
we have all rounder wicket keeper
batter and bowler
so majorly
there are all rounders in the auction
followed by bowlers then we have 17.69
percent battles and ten point eleven
percent wicket keepers which is the
lowest
cool
now
we are going to create another bar plot
or a bar graph that will tell us how
many players were sold and unsold
so for this i am going to use a count
plot so we will create two bars one for
sold and the other one for unsold and
each of the bars will have different
colors
one will have orange the other one will
have pink and i'm using labels so to
label the x-axis and y-axis i have sold
or unsold by label will have number of
players the title of my bar graph would
be sold versus unsold i'm given a font
size of 15 and i'm saying
plt.plot
now the function that you see here at
the bottom
will display the data labels for each of
the bars
let me just run it and show you the
result there you go
so i have used a figure size of 10 comma
5
all right now you can see we have a
really good
bar plot which says there were total 237
players sold and 396 players were unsold
as per the data we have
cool
now
you can also
print
the total sold and unsold values let me
show you how to do it
i'll say ipl
dot we can use the group by function
and i want to group it by
status column
and
the value that i want to measure is
the player's
count so i'll say players
rather player
and then i'm going to use the
count function if i run this you can see
here
i've successfully grouped the unsold and
sold players the values are matching
with
the bar plot that we just created so
sold where 237 players are unsold are
396.
cool
now we are going to see the total number
of players bought by each team again
this is going to be a count plot so
basically a bar plot
so here the condition i'm passing is
in the teams column the value shouldn't
be unsold
so
players bought means the value should be
sold so here i am using this condition
and the rest of the things remains the
same
one improvement i have done here is i am
using x6 rotation equal to 70 degrees
this basically means the x labels would
be tilted by 70 degrees
now let's see
the bar plot there you go so here you
can see i have the title players bought
by each team on the y-axis we have the
number of players
and on the x-axis you can see the values
have been tilted by
70 degrees let me just zoom in so that
you can see it better
and this is the bar plot
so the maximum a team can purchase is 25
players some of the teams have also
purchased 24 22 and 23 players let me
just show you so
gujarat titans have totally purchased 22
players
then
delhi capitals have totaled 24 players
in their squad
again
lucknow supergiants have 22 players
if i scroll and see again
bangalore loyal challengers or rcb
they're all challenges bangalore have
22 players in the team
and rajasthan royals and sunrises
hyderabad have
24 and 23 players respectively in their
teams
all right
now
we will create three more columns
called
retention base price
and base price unit
for that
first of all i am creating a new column
called retention which is equal to
ipl base price let me just run it
and then i'm going to replace
these values that are present in the
list 2 crore 40 lakh 20 lakh 1 crore 30
lakh 1.5 crore
with
from auction
and i'm saying in place equal to true
let me just run it
then we are going to
treat the base price
so here
in the base price
column i am going to replace
draft pick value as
0 so let's run that as well
and now
i'm going to split
the base price
value into two separate values called
bree spice unit and beast price so
basically i'm splitting
on this piece
that i have let me show you how it is
going to split
so this is let's see our
base price column
what i did was i
replaced the draft pick values to zero
and then the rest of the values will be
split into two columns called base price
unit so basically it will have the
unit
of the base price let's say crores or
lakhs
and
the base underscore price column will
have the value which is 2 here 40
20 20 so on and so forth
let me just scroll down
and
run that particular cell
now to create
these two columns the base price unit
column and the base underscore price
column i have used the lambda function
and i'm splitting based on the space
let's just run it
now i have replaced
retained with 0
and
let me show you the
final data frame that i have
so here you can see we have replaced
the draft pick values in the base price
column to zero
and on the right side you can see the
three different columns that i wanted to
create so one is called retention
so zeroes refer to draft pick
any other value
will say
the player was picked from the auction
then you have the base price
unit so here
you can see crores
lacks
and the value base prices 2
40 so on and so forth
cool
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
now
let's check how many players were
retained and bought from the auction by
each of the teams
so i'll say
ipl let me just scroll down
dot
i'm going to use the
group by function
then i'll say
team
comma
retention
and i am going to
use the value
as
retention because i want to find the
count of
retained players
then i'll say colon
-1
let me run it
you can see here
the different team names because i have
grouped by team and then retention so i
have changed super kings from the
auction they had picked
21 players and they had retained
four players coming to delhi capitals
delhi capitals in the 2022
ipl auction they picked total 20 players
and they have retained four similarly if
i scroll down let me talk about let's
say punjab kings they have
pegged 23 players from the auction and
retained two players from
the team last year
talking about
rcb or all challenges bangalore they
have picked 19 players from the auction
and they have retained
three players
all right
now in the next cell of code
we are going to display the players in
each team
based on the different types of players
so let me just run it and show you the
result
so here i am using the same condition
the value shouldn't be equal to
unsold
and i am going to use another parameter
called hue for the different colors so
here i have used hue
as type because i want to
show the players in each team based on
the different types
again i have given my
title to the bar plot
and then i have the x label the y label
and my rotation is 50 degrees now
if i scroll down you can see the
different
types of players here is the legend so
blue is for blue
orange or yellow
it's for all rounder green is for batter
and red
which also looks like maroon is for
wicket keepers
and on the
x-axis you can see the different team
names
all right
now let's answer another
couple of questions so here i have
what is the highest amount spent on a
single player by each team
so to solve this question i'll say
my data frame name that is ipl
then i am going to say
retention
equal to equal to
this should be from auction because
you want to see the highest amount spent
and not
from the retained players
then i am going to
group
by
i'll say
team
and then
i'll say
cost
in
let me just copy it from here
cost in rupees
that is in crores
and
i'll say
max colon
-1
dot
sort underscore
values
i'll say ascending
equal to false which means i want the
sorted
result in descending order
okay
let me just
bring this
to the left side and we'll run it
there seems to be some error let me
check the error it sees
there's a spelling mistake this should
be
team
let me run it again there you go
so you can see
mumbai indians
have spent
15.25 crores
for one of the players and
this player happens to be sean kissen
then
chennai super kings have spent the
highest amount for
a player who happens to be a bowler the
name is deepak chahar they have bought
him for 14 crores kolkata knight riders
bought
shreyas ayer for 12.25 crores
and so on and so forth
so these are the highest amounts spent
on a single player by each of the teams
let me scroll down
now we are going to see the player
retained at
maximum value or maximum price
now if you follow ipl the maximum
price
at which a player was retained happens
to be ravindra jadeja so let's see at
what price was he retained
i'll say
retention
equal to equal to i'll say
retained
then i'll say
sort underscore
values
by equal to
i'll use the
same column
cost in
rupees
that's in crores
i'll say
ascending equal to
false
dot
head
and i want to find the top player
again there's some error
let's see
where is the error
this is ascending equal to false
dot head
okay this should be
sort underscore
values
within bracket i should say
by
i think this should be
fine now let's run it
there you go
so you can see here our result is player
name ravindra jadeja who was retained
for
16 crores by chennai super kings
cool
now
the next cell of code will
display or print the top five bowlers
who have been picked
in this year's ipl based on
their cost in inr
let me just run it and show you the
result
you can see here deepak chahar went for
14 crores then we have shraddha thakur
who was bought by
delhi capitals earlier he was part of
csk
for 10.75 crores then we have prasada
krishna who has been bought by rajasthan
royals this time
last year he was with keker and he has
been bought for 10 crores similarly loki
ferguson has been bought by gujarat
titans and he played for kkr last season
he has been bought for 10 crores while
his base price was too close then we
have avish khan
you can see avishkhan's base price was
just 20 lakhs and he has been bought for
10 crores by lucknow super giants again
and last year he was part of the daily
capitals
now you can replace
this value
suppose let's say you want to find the
top five batsman's picked or battles
picked with the highest amount you can
just see
batter instead of bowler and if i run
this
you can see here
srya sayer was bought by kolkata night
riders for 12.25 crores last year he was
part of delhi capitals
then you have
shimran haitmaia who's from
west indies he has been picked by the
rajasthan royals for
eight point five crores then we have
rahul tribati
sikha dhaban and that particle
now if you wanted to check for
let's see all round those you can
replace batter with all-rounder
if i run this
you can see
lamb livingstone has been bought by
punjab kings this season
for
11.5 crores his beast price was just one
crore and last year he was part of the
rajasthan royals
then we have a player from sri lanka
asaranga then we have hershel patel
shahrukh khan and rahul devatia who have
been
the top five all-rounders picked at
highest amount
cool
finally
we want to
see the players who were part of the ipl
last season but we're not picked for
this year's ipl
so for that what i'm doing is first i'm
renaming my
2021 squad column
this column i want to
rename it as previous team
let's run it
then
i am going to find out the unsold
players so here i am saying previous
team not equal to
not participated
and then i'm using another condition
team should be equal to equal to unsold
and i'm going to find out only the
player and the previous team
so let's run it and see the result
so here you can see
these players were part of the ipl last
season but
they haven't been picked this season and
last season they had played for let's
say surah shrine update for csk steve
smith was part of the delhi capitals
suckabol
was part of kkr if i scroll down you
have david mullan who played for punjab
kings in 2021
in morgan
who played for kkr he also captained kkr
but unfortunately he was
not picked the season chris lane from
australia also
remained unsold this season
and to tie we have been cutting aditya
there are other players as well
we have kane richardson dhawal kulkarni
cool so these were the players who were
part of the ipl season 2021 but
unfortunately were not picked and
remained unsold for 2022 season
cool
and that brings us to our
end of this demo session on
ipl data analysis 2022 so we learned
how to
use the different functions
and attributes that are part of
the
python libraries and we manipulated the
data we visualized the data and
answered some specific questions
in this video we'll be using four
publicly available data sets about
formula one that has information from
1950 to the 2019 f1 season
we'll see how using the python libraries
you can perform explority data analysis
and draw valuable insights
so let's begin by understanding what
formula one is
formula one also known as f1 is a motor
sport defined by open wheeled single
sheet race cars
it features the best drivers in the most
powerful and technically advanced cars
the sport is governed by the fia that is
international automobile federation here
10 teams comprising of two drivers each
compete in a series of races over a
period of one year to find out the
ultimate driver and a constructor
champion
in our demonstration we'll be using four
data sets let me show them one by one
these are all csv files
now this is the first data set that
we'll be using in our demo so if you
notice the data set does not have
columns
names in fact none of the data sets have
column names so while importing the data
set we will assign the column names
using the names parameter
i'll show that in a
while
now this is the results data set
the results data set has information
about
result id
then we have the race id driver id
we have
the constructor id
grid position
then we also have information about the
fastest
lap then we also have information about
rank the fastest lap speed
and the status id
now moving on to the second data set
which is about
races
now this is the second data set which is
about races so
it has information about the race id
the year in which the race was held then
we have
the round number circuit id
then the name of the
grand prix so you can see here australia
and malaysia and chinese spanish monaco
turkish british german
and others
then we have the
date on which the gp was held or the
grand prix was
held
we have the time and a url which
basically leads to the wikipedia page of
that particular
grand prix for that year
now moving on to our third data set
so this is our third data set which is
about
drivers
now it has the driver id the name of the
driver you can see here hamilton rosberg
alonso
ryken
then we have sato
masa
button weber and all
after that we have the
number code
then we have the
phone name of the driver the surname of
the driver
and then we have the date of birth of
that particular driver we have the
nationality as well
we have the wikipedia page
for the
driver
now moving on to the last data set which
is about
constructors so this is the fourth and
the final data set that we'll be using
in our data analysis project
so here we have the constructor id
then the constructor reference
in formula one
and this is the actual name of the
constructor so we have mclaren
we have
bmw sauber williams then we have ferrari
toyota red bull force india
we also have jordan jaguar and all
next we have the
nationality and the url
that is the wikipedia page of
that particular constructor
now let's head over to our jupiter
notebook and we'll start with our
analysis
here is my jupyter notebook that i'll be
using for this demo you can see some of
the cells are already filled this is
just to make sure we
save some time
so using these data sets that we just
saw and our library such as numpy pandas
matplotlib and c-bond
we'll answer specific questions such as
the drivers and constructors who have
been the most successful throughout the
history of f1 sport
then we'll explore the impact of
starting and finishing positions and the
speed of the cars has changed over the
years
so let's begin with our analysis
first and foremost we are going to
import all the necessary libraries so
here i am importing numpy pandas
matplotlib and cbon and after that i am
writing percentage matplotlib inline
that is to ensure that
all the plots are embedded in line i'll
hit shift enter to run it
take some time there you go so we have
successfully imported all the libraries
now the next step is to
load the data and assign
column names
so
i load my
first data which is results i'll say pd
dot
read underscore
csv
i'll give my
file name which is results dot
csv
and then
using the
names parameter
i'll pass in the
column names so actually i have written
the column names in a notepad let me
open that
so i have this f1
notepad created which has the column
names i'll just start copying
the column names
within the names parameter i'll paste it
if i scroll to the right you can see the
different column names that
have been assigned
and
that
i'm going to say
comma
and i'll write
header equal to none
i'll close the bracket
cool
similarly let's
import the second data set which is
about
races i'll say
pd dot
read underscore csv
i'll give my
file name which is races.csv
and then
i'll give the
names parameter this is actually names
and not name
okay
i'm going to
copy the second line
and i'll paste it here
and again
i'll say
header
equal to
none
next
we'll import our third data set which is
about
drivers
so i'll say pd dot read underscore csv
i'll
say drivers dot csv
then
again use the
names parameter
and i'll copy the
third line now which has the column
names
for the
drivers data set
here
i
need to give
another parameter which is
header
equal to
none
finally we are going to import our
constructors data set
it's a constructors equal to pd dot
read underscore csv which is the
function present in the pandas library
i'll say
constructors.csv which is my
file name
and then again i'll use the names
parameter
i'll go to my notepad and this time i'll
copy the
fourth line which has the column names
for the constructors data set
i'll paste it
and
here i'll give my
final parameter that is header equal to
none
all right now
let me hit shift enter to
run it
okay we see some error here let's debug
the error it says
no such file or directory drivers dot
csv
let's see
where was the issue
this should be
driver.csv
cool now we have successfully loaded the
data and assigned the
columns to the various data sets
now the
next analysis
is to merge all the data set
so here i'll create a data frame called
df and i'll use
pd dot
merge function
first i'll use the
results data frame that we just
imported above
this one
and
i'm going to
merge it with
racist data frame
and from the resist data frame i am
going to take
specific columns like the
race id
then
i need the
year
after that i need
name
next
i'm going to take
the round column as well
and
i'm going to use
on parameter so
on parameter
is actually
the column that is common to both the
data frames that is results and recess
so here my common column
is going to be the race id because it is
present in both the data sets
and i would like to merge
so for that i'm going to use how so i'm
going to use a left join
so
if you know sql you will be aware of
left join it takes all the rows from the
left table
and only the matching rows from the
right table
i'm again going to use the merge
function so i'll write
df equal to pd dot
merge
i'll say
df comma and now i'm going to
merge the
ivor's data set
and
i am going to select
specific columns so i will say
driver id
make sure there are no spelling mistakes
in the
column names
then i'll say
driver
rdf which is the name of the driver or
reference
comma
and then i want the
nationality of the
driver
all right
we'll give a comma i'll say on
which column i want to merge so here the
common column
is going to be the driver id
again
how is going to be a left join
into the final
merge part i'll say again df equal to pd
dot
merge
i'll pass in my data frame and my final
data set which i have is about
constructors
from constructors we are going to choose
specific columns so i'll take the
constructor
id
then
i'll take
the name column
and again the
nationality column of the
manufacturer
okay
here i say
on
equal to
the common column i'll use this
constructor id
you give a comma and say how
equal to
left again
make sure
you're merging it with the
right column names so let's run this
cell to merge
all the four data sets
i'll hit
enter
oops there is some error let's see it
says constructor
id index
okay there's a spelling mistake this
should be
constructor id cool
let's run it
there you go
now
the next thing we want to do is to drop
the unnecessary columns
so i'll say df.drop
within the drop function
we are going to pass in the
column names i'll say
number
then we also don't want the
position column
next we have position underscore
text
after that we have
labs
next we are going to
drop fastest
lap
then we'll also drop the
status id
comma
we'll drop the
result underscore id column
then
going to drop the race underscore id
column
we'll also drop
driver underscore id column
and finally we are going to drop
the
constructor underscore id column
and
i'll say access equal to 1
and in place i'll c equal to true
because i want to remove it from my
original data frame that is df
there you go
now the next
thing i want to do is i want to rename
some of the columns so i'll say df dot
rename
i'll say
columns equal to
now we are going to pass in a dictionary
i'm going to change the
rank
to
test
underscore lab underscore rank
let me give a comma
now i'll say
name underscore x
equal to
i'll say the
grand prix name so i'll say gp
underscore name
next column i'm going to focus is
the nationality column so i'll say
nationality underscore
x
i'll give a colon the value i'm going to
pass in is
driver nationality
all right
up
next we have one column called
underscore
y
and that i am going to change it to
constructor name
another comma
i'm going to say
nationality
underscore
y
colon
change it to
constructor nationality
underscore nationality
finally we have
driver
underscore ref column
and that i'm going to replace with
just
driver
finally i'll say
in place
equal to
true
just verify if all the column names are
correct
let's run it
all right so now we have
successfully renamed
the columns
after that
in the next cell i am going to rearrange
the columns so here i am
using the same data frame and we have
just renamed the columns so starting
with your
grand pre name round driver
nationality
and others
let's run this
up next
we're going to drop the
2019 season data because
it is incomplete
so i'll say df equal to
df
then i'll say
here
not
equal to
2090
let's see how to
sort the values so i'll say df equal to
df dot
sort underscore values which is the
function name i am going to sort it by
year
followed by
round
followed by
the
position
underscore
order
comma i'll say
ascending equal to
first let's say is false
next i have true
and then
i'll have true
all right
moving ahead
now we are going to see how to replace
the
put slash
n values in
the time column with
something called nan because the time
column was not registered when a driver
did not finish a race or was lagged by
another driver
so to do this i am going to say
df dot
time
dot i'm going to use the replace
function
and here i'll say
forward slash
or backward slash
n
and i'm going to replace with
numpies nan
i'll say
in place equal to true
let me just copy this because we are
going to use the same
emitters
next i am going to replace the
milliseconds value
milliseconds dot
replace i'll paste it here
then i'll say df dot
fastest
underscore lab underscore
rank dot
replace
paste it
next i have
d up dot
fastest dot
lab
dot
time
series
to that i have the next column which is
speed so i'll say fastest
underscore
lap underscore
speed dot
replace
i'll paste it
so here
i'm going to replace
this particular value
the
backward slash
n with
nan
let me run it
cool
step i'm going to
change the data types for
fastest underscore lab underscore speed
to float then fastest underscore lab
underscore rank to float again
now
problem here is we cannot convert it
into an integer because there are
missing values so we are going to change
it to float
again for milliseconds also we are
changing it to float values
let me run it
now
i'll reset the index
let me show you how to reset the index
i'll say df
dot reset
underscore
index
and say
drop
equal to
true
give a comma and say
in place equal to true
all right
we have
done our initial
processing step of the data set
now we'll check the shape of the data
set then we see all the data sets the
total number of non-null values the
memory usage and we'll
check the head of the data set
now to see the total number of
rows and columns i'll say
print df dot
shape
you can see here there are total 24
197 rows in my data set and there are
total of 15 columns
now let's use
df dot
info
function so it gives me the
year the grand prix name
the round number
driver constructor name grid
position order total number of points
time
then time in milliseconds the fastest
slap rank
the fastest lap speed
the nationality of the driver the
nationality of the constructor
then here we have the
total number of non-null objects
and then you also have the memory usage
at the bottom
finally let's see the
head of the data frame so i'll see
df dot
head let's say i want to check the first
10 rows
where you go
if i scroll down you can see here we
have the top 10 rows printed
and you have the year the grand prix
name round driver constructor name and
other columns now let me just
brief you about what these column names
stand for
so the year column that you see here
is the season that the grand prix took
place
and then we have the
name of the grand prix
now the round column is the number of
the race in each season for example one
means it was the first race of the
season and then two means it was the
second race of the season so so on and
so forth
then we have the name of the driver
for that we have the
name of the car constructor so you can
see ferrari mercedes red bull renault
then we have the grid that is the
starting position before the race
actually this depends on the
qualifications which occur one day
before the race
then we have the position underscore
order column this means the final
position at the end of the race then we
have the points column that is the total
number of points scored in the race
next we have the time that is the amount
of time that took to finish the race
only the winners time is displayed and
drivers behind the winner are shown how
far behind the winner they are
then we have the milliseconds column
that is the amount of time that took to
finish the race in milliseconds
if i just scroll down
i'll just move to the
right
go to the top
then we have the fastest underscore lab
underscore rank that is the order of the
fastest lab during race
next we have
fastest lap time that is the shortest
amount of time that took to complete a
lap in the release
then we have the lap speed that is the
average speed of the
fastest lap
then we have the
country to which the driver belongs to
and then we have the
constructor nationality that is the
country where the car constructor is
based out of
okay
now
here i am going to
set my figure size to 10 comma 6 this is
going to be for all the
plots that we are going to create
afterwards
cool
we'll create a data frame that will have
all the grand prix winners
so here i am going to say
driver
underscore
winner equal to
use my data frame
df dot i'll say loc
then i'll say
df
i want
the position
underscore order
and that should be equal to 1 so which
means
the driver 1 degrees
and then
i am going to
use the
group by function
i'm going to group it by
driver
and
for values i'll say
position underscore
order
use the
count function
followed by
sort underscore
values
i'll say
ascending equal to
false
we change it to
to underscore
frame
dot
reset
underscore index
what essentially i am doing here is i am
finding out
all the drivers that have participated
and
won a grand prix
next
i'm going to create a
bar plot so this is going to be the
first visualization of our analysis
so i'll say
sb
which we have taken in our
analysis ideally it should be sns but sb
also will work
so i'll say sb
dot
bar plot
i'm going to say data equal to
driver underscore
winner
the y-axis i'll have
driver
in the x-axis i'll have
position
underscore
order
then i have
color equal to
green
that i'll set my
alpha value to
0.5
or let's say
0.8
then
we are going to
give a title to our plot so i'll say plt
dot
title
let's say most
grand prix
winners in f1
then we are going to label our axis so
for y label i will have
driver
name
we have
the x label
that will have
number of
grand prix wins
and i'll say
plt dot
y
tex
cool
let's run it
and you can see we have our first
bar plot here now the bar plot
shows that there are
a large distribution of
grand prix wins
only a few drivers in history
of f1 have won over 20 grand prey in
their careers and there are some drivers
who completely dominated the f1 racing
and have won over
50 grand praise in their careers so we
are going to focus on those
top five or top 10
drivers
in the next section so what i am doing
here is
from the
above
result that we just got i'm going to
filter out only the
top 10 so i'm going to use the head
function
and
inside that i passed in 10 if i print it
you can see here
as per the data that we have
we have michael schumacher who
is the position
order leader with 91 gp events then we
have hamilton vettel frost senna
alonso
then we have stevert clerk and louder
the data that we have is
not the most recent one so if you check
the actual stats hamilton has actually
overtaken michael sumacher and has won
over 103
close to 103 races as of now
and next we have michael sumacre so this
is not the most recent data
cool
now using this data we'll create another
bar plot for the top 10
drivers so i'll say sb dot
bar plot
i'll say data equal to
the
name that we have used that is top 10
drivers so i'll say top 10
drivers
in the y axis we'll have
the
driver name
in the x-axis we'll have
position
underscore
order
for the bars i'm going to use a color
equal to
let's say blue this time
i'll set my alpha value
to be
0.8
and
i'll say let's say
line
width
equal to
0.8
and i'll also give
an edge color of let's say black
follow the same drill i'm going to give
a title to my plot so i'll say plt dot
title
most
gp
winners in a phone
will give a y label
that says
driver
name
and then i'll have
x label which will have
number of
entry
bins
cool
let me see if everything is fine
and then we'll
run this there you go
you can see we have a very nice
horizontal
bar plot that shows the
top drivers in f1 so as per our data
that we have we have michael schumacher
who has won over 91 or close to
91
races then we have hamilton vettel
alonso clark and others
all right
in the same way we are going to create
bar plot for the top constructors that
have participated in f1
so here i'm finding out
all the
constructor winners so here
i'm using my position underscore order
equal equal to 1 and then i'm using the
group by
based on the constructor name
and then i'm finding the count of
position order and sorting the values
in
descending order and i'm changing it to
frame or to a data frame
and to create my bar plot i'm using the
bar plot function the data which is
constructor underscore winner
in the y-axis i'll have the constructor
name on the x-axis i'll have the
position order
so you can see here i've used color as
pink and i've given a title x label by
label
and vitix
let's run it
there you go so here you can see again
the data is
widely spread
so we have a lot of constructor names
now
our next task is to
check the
top 10 gpa constructor windows so here
i'm using the head function and finding
out the top 10 if i run it
you can see here
the manufacturing companies or the
constructors who have won the most
number of
races
are ferrari
mclaren williams then we have mercedes
red bull tim lotus renault
and others
okay
now we'll convert this data into a
horizontal
bar graph or a bar chart
so that will show the bar plot for the
top 10
constructors
now let me show you how to do it
so i'll say
is b which is for c bond dot
bar plot
going to say data equal to
top 10 let me just confirm
the name we have top 10 constructors
scroll down i'll see constructors
y axis i'll have
constructor
the x-axis i'll have
position underscore order
then
i'll say
color
equal to let's say we'll use the
red color for the bars
then i'll set my
alpha to
0.8
i'll say
line width equal to
0.8
and my
edge
color i'll say
black
that i'll say plt dot
title
say
top 10
most gp
wins
lt dot
by label would be
constructor
name
and i'll have plt dot
x label
as
number of
gp
wins
cool
let's run it
there you go so here you can see we have
ferrari at the top then we have mclaren
williams more cities i'm pretty certain
by
the end of 2021 season mercedes would
have gained a lot of wins
since hamilton has been on the top
for mercedes for quite some time now
all right
now
finally we are going
to create a
regression plot that will
show how
two variables that is the starting
position and finishing
position
vary
so to do that i'm going to exclude the
data points with grid 0 because it skews
the data so 0 means that the driver
started from the
pit lane
so
i'm using this function called reg
plot
to plot my
regression line
let me run it and show you the result
there you go
so if you see here
we can easily see there's a linear
relationship between the
starting and
finishing position so on the x-axis we
have the starting position on the y-axis
we have the
finishing or the finished place
so which is what is actually expected
right now we can also see that most
races had up to
25 drivers you can see the density of
the points here
but
some of the recess also had over 30
drivers you can see the
light color blue dots
next
we are going to
check whether the speed of the cars
changed over the years since this data
is only available from 2004 onwards so
we have
we have taken
years that start from 2004 onwards
now let me show you the result
of this
data so essentially we are plotting the
average speed among
all teams during the fastest lap at
individual grand prix
and here on the
y axis you have the average fastest
speed in kilometer per hour and then you
have the different
gps
and
you can see here the year values
now in general what we see is there's a
decrease in the average fastest lap from
2004
till around 2015
for almost all the circuits and again
from 2015 onward the speed started
to increase
you can see here there's an increase
after 2015 there's an increase there's
an increase here as well
you can also notice that
the speed is very different on each
track for instance if you check the
italian grand prix which is here
italian gp has the
fastest race in the calendar with
average speed exceeding over
240 kilometers per hour on the other
hand if you
talk about the
monaco grand prix let me show you if you
see here
the monaco gp is the slowest race with
average speed below
160 kilometer per hour now this is
actually expected because the monaco
grand prix
has very narrow streets and
hence the drivers cannot
drive fast in this circuit
all right
and with that we have come to an end of
this session on software development
projects for beginners in 2022. thank
you for our expert trainers for being
with us and thank you viewers i hope the
session was interesting and informative
if you have any queries regarding any of
the topics covered in this session or if
you require the resources that we used
in this session then please do let us
know in the comment section below and
our team of experts will be more than
happy to resolve all your queries as the
earliest until next time thank you stay
safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you